Ah,ióch...
So, checkt mal Blitz, bescheuertere Online-Satz kann man auch nicht machen Leute, also checkt
mal Blitz ob Quality-Settings und so alle am Start sind, also sprich ob ihr 1080p mit
ungefähr 8 MBit gucken könnt, ich kann auch mal kurz checken.
Ja, wo sieht man hier nochmal die Details, Details, wo sind sie hier, ja perfekt, also
das heißt das Spiel sollte jetzt auch relativ gut aussehen, ja das ist Bad Company 2 Ost,
das war als Battlefield noch ein Soundtrack hatte und nicht nur, das war jetzt ungefähr
der Original Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 2 Soundtrack in 5 Sekunden, ja habe ich alles
neu vergeben, nie Battlefield 5 gespielt, na doch, die Beta, hat mich aber nicht so
geschockt muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich habe Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 kaum gespielt,
ne stimmt nicht, umgedreht was, umgedreht was, Battlefield 1 habe ich die Beta gespielt
und hatte dann keinen Bock auf das, wobei doch, ich habe das Finale Spiel, ich weiß
es nicht mehr genau, aber Battlefield 5 habe ich tatsächlich gekauft, hatte aber kaum
Bock zu spielen.
1080 ist halt eigentlich zu wenig, ja ich denke das geht schon, das werden wir gleich
sehen, gucken wir mal, mit was, lass mal kurz gucken, mit was streamt der Lost für Settings,
das muss ich jetzt mal checken, der weiß ja was man, der weiß ja wie es geht, der weiß
ja wie es geht, also der weiß ja wie man Game Streams, ah Big Brain, Big Brain niedrigere
Auflösung, ok, ok, das schon mal, 5-Fed-Time, so, Video-Stats, der Lost hat was an der eingestellt,
guck mal der hat nur 6 MBit, da komme ich 1080p mit knapp 8 MBit auch hin, wird schon
passen, so Leute, ich habe gerade eine Stunde Sport gemacht, was gefuttert, also ich bin
überhaupt nicht eingespielt, aber gestern, ich sag euch, ich habe so gebashed zwischendurch,
das ist ja der Wahnsinn, aber das Balancing von dem Game ist auch wild, wirklich sagt
man ja heutzutage, wild, wild ist die Vorstufe von Lost quasi, also das Balancing ist wirklich
wild von Battlefield 2042, wild, also man muss sich das mal überlegen, die haben es
geschafft, ich zeige euch das jetzt, wir starten das jetzt einfach, Bäm, wo sind wir, ich
mach mal kurz Soundtrack aus, wir müssen jetzt mal kurz checken, ob Sound, Lautstärke und
sowas alles funktioniert, ich zeige euch das mal kurz, also ich weiß nicht, was bei DICE
da jetzt so genau im Kopf vorgeht, ich hoffe das Game läuft ordentlich, wenn ich streame
im Hintergrund, erstmal Rootkit starten, ganz wichtig, mittlerweile ist ja Anti-Cheat quasi,
es gibt kein Anti-Cheat ohne Rootkit mehr, Colonel Dreiber alles am Start, Ram auslesen,
Passwörter auslesen, easy gar kein Ding, na ich weiß nicht, ob das so poc ist, eigentlich
finde ich das wenig poc, weil wenn man auf den einschlägigen Cheat Seiten guckt, das
ist schon wieder in vollem Gange zu Battlefield 2042, ist easy cheat nicht das was Apex verwendet?
Apex, Apex nennt auch, so, also ganz wichtig, das erste was man machen muss ist, Draw, nee,
Perf, Perf, Alter ich kann ja nicht mehr schreiben, Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS, 1, so, diese Anzeige
hier oben ist mega für den Arsch, ich hab keine Ahnung was sie bedeuten soll, aber
wenns rot wird ruckelts, ich hab, wie gesagt, also ich vermute mal, dass oben ist das interessante
oder ich hab keine Ahnung, ich checks nicht, oder das oder ich, also, ja, genau, PpoG,
PpoG, danke für die Subs, Leute, es kann sein, dass ich heute ein bisschen, ein bisschen
übersehen werde, also richtig, PpoG starts, aber, es wird rot wenns ruckelt, so jetzt
müssen wir mal checken, ob, jetzt wir machen jetzt einfach mal ne Testrunde, gucken wir
ob der Sound und sowas passt, das ist übrigens normal, dass hier kein Sound ist, die rauscht
so ein bisschen im Hintergrund, ich baller klein mal ingame rum und dann checken wir
es, passt mal auf, also, DICE hat sich gedacht, es ist ne gute Idee, quasi alles auf eine
Stelle, es ruckelt, ruckelts bei euch, es ruckelt, es ruckelt hart, wait a minute, warum ruckelten
das so, was ist hier los, Moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz ausprobieren, ich spawn
mal kurz in der Base, warum ruckelten das so, Alter, Monka, was jetzt, jetzt gehts, Monka,
Alter, jetzt funktionierts oder, Alter, was, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich muss das minimieren,
irgendwas ist hier mega im Arsch, what the, ich hab lack of doom beim, ok jetzt gehts
halbwegs, ok, ok, ok, kann das sein, ok, ich glaub das müssen wir anders machen, display
capture aus, wartet mal, das ist repp, das funktioniert nicht, game capture an, ok, so
und jetzt aber den Ton bisschen lauter, 1080 Ti hab ich, ist das besser jetzt, ok, ich
muss mal kurz auf dem Handy angucken, wie die Quali ist, weil ich hab, ich mach so selten
Game Streams, oh fuck, ich muss mich einloggen auf Twitch, da muss ich auf den zweiten Bildschirm
gucken, im Fullscreen, mal kurz Vorschau gucken, ob das in 1080p in Ordnung aussieht, das sieht
verhältnismäßig gut aus, wisst ihr das, also es geht, sieht eigentlich wirklich ganz
ok aus, ok, nice, GG Eats, was soll ich machen, ich soll den Sound lauter machen, check, check
mal kurz, der Sound, Sound-Lautstärke müsste doch ein halbwegs passen, würd ich jetzt mal
vermuten oder, ich kann auch nen Ticken lauter machen, das ist kein Ding also, ich, ich kann
auch, ich kann auch ein bisschen hier, komm ich mach noch einfach so, so hier, also, äh,
die haben sich gedacht, die Jungs, jetzt müssen wir hier kurz mal stelsen, also, die haben sich
gedacht, sie packen einfach alles was OP ist auf eine Klasse, ich hab keine Ahnung was
mit Dice los ist, also du kannst, das hier, das ist so ein hyper krass OP Shit, oh fuck
mein Mousepad ist schepp, guck mal, du kannst jetzt einfach easy, hui, so easy, das hast
du, du hast, guck mal, ich, ich, ich hab Movement of Doom, ich hab nen fucking Midi-Pack am Start,
ich hab nen Assault Rifle mit ACOG über Range, ich, ich weiß beim besten Willen nicht was
ich Dice dabei gedacht hat, also, das Ding hat unendlich Schuss, das Ding hat unendlich
Schuss, guck mal, und, und, guck mal, je nachdem wie ich das mach, kannst du damit sogar,
kannst du damit sogar Falldamage ab, abfangen, das ist OP as fuck, ok wir sind hier ziemlich
am Arsch, aber, komm, irgendwas schießt hier auf mich, pass mal auf, und jetzt, heute ist
übrigens der Test Stream, ob das Spiel Skill-Best Matchmaking hat, gestern hab ich die krassesten
Runden hier oft mal live gehabt, ich hab fast kaum ne Runde unter 40 Kills gespielt, und
wenn ich heute nur auf den Sack kriege, dann ist Skill-Best Matchmaking da, muss ja so
sein, muss ja so sein, es kann nicht sein, dass ich heute schlecht spiele, ich hab jetzt
einfach die Ausrede, wenn es schlecht ist, dann kann ich sagen Skill-Best Matchmaking,
da hängt überhaupt keiner dran, seht ihr das, der ist einfach weg, achja, übrigens
man kann die Map nicht aufmachen, das ist kaputt, ok, wir stellts jetzt da rüber, da werden
wir wahrscheinlich gebashed, guck, guck, guck, da stellts da schon, da stellts da schon
da, dude, easy, da stellts da schon, oh, ups, ich wollte den Midi-Pack schmeißen, guck
mal hier, da sind sie, da werden sie gebashed, Massive, next, whoa, next, let's go, what
up, ich muss weg, es ruckelt, es ruckelt, also Leute, immer wenn es rechts oben, immer
wenn es rechts oben dippt, dann ist die Kacke am Dampfen, dann kriege ich nichts auf die
Reihe, also es ist auf jeden Fall mit Stream im Hintergrund deutlich laggier als gestern,
guck mal, das ist so OP, das ist einfach krasser OP-Shit, du kannst einfach aufs Dach, niemand
kann aufs Dach hoch, oh, also ich weiß nicht, wer sich bei DICE gedacht hat, dass das eine
gute Idee ist, dass alles, ja ja, lass mich nur, dass alles auf die gleiche Klasse zu
packen, komm hier nicht rüber, guck mal, der stellts hier übelst rum, ach ja, übrigens,
man sieht Gegner auch mega schlecht, also wenn ihr nicht wisst, an was ich sterbe, dann
geht davon aus, ach das ist meiner, ja manchmal ist es auch echt, dann geht davon aus, ich
weiß es auch nicht, und ja, also weißt du, alter, seht ihr wie das ruckelt zwischendurch,
das sind krasse Dips, guck mal, ich kann mich sogar heilen, das ist so fail, lul, guck mal,
jetzt hat es einfach geruggelt und ich war down, also das ist, die Performance ist doch
wirklich der Wahnsinn, okay, ja, das ist übrigens auch so was, was ein bisschen suckt, du weißt
nicht so genau, ob dich jetzt einer retzt oder nicht, ich hatte schon öfters, dass
ich Leute retzen wollte und dann haben die released, ich nenne das mal, ich nenne das
releasing, das ist so alte MMO-Angewohnheit und das ist alles noch ein bisschen, guck
mal, pass mal auf, guck mal, das ist so OP, okay, das war jetzt ziemlich, das ist so
OP, ich kann einfach überall hoch, das Movement ist krass, also das ist wirklich, also ihr
müsst euch mal vorstellen, ich habe Movement Skills, ich habe die besten, übrigens mein
grappling hook ist gerade kaputt gegangen, jetzt geht er wieder, ich habe die besten
Movement Skills im Game, ich habe ein Medi-Pack, um mich selbst zu heilen, ich habe mit die
besten Waffen, mit Assault Rifles am Start, ich kann Squad-Mates retzen, weil das kann
ja jeder, das ist so brutal OP, also du musst eigentlich Webster spielen, du kannst eigentlich
nichts anderes da machen, übrigens es ruckelt alle 5 Sekunden, das geht mir ja ziemlich
auf den Sack, sag mal, sind hier überhaupt irgendwo noch Gegner oder werden die gerade,
die Gegner werden gerade extrem hart weggebasht, also ohne Scheiß, Leute, in einem Spiel,
was so vertikal ist, wie dieses Battlefield, was so vertikal ist, ist einfach, es ist einfach
OP, du kannst, Map aufmachen kann man nicht, Map aufmachen kann man nicht, Map aufmachen
geht nicht, Map aufmachen ist broken, sonst hätte ich schon längst auf die Map geguckt,
wow, schreck mich nicht so, Alter, also ihr müsst jetzt mal gucken, ist Quali gut, läuft
flüssig, dann lasse ich nämlich einfach alles so, ich meine, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
ich kann jetzt einfach sagen, ah ja, zack, sind wir oben, ansonsten finde ich den Speed
und so finde ich wirklich gut in dem Game, ohne Scheiß, also das gefällt mir, guck mal,
du hast keine, da oben ist, aber soweit geht das nicht, oder, ne, aber ich kann euch mal
zeigen, wie man da hochkommt, es gibt einen Fahrstuhl, es gibt einen Fahrstuhl, da kann
man, wo ist der, hier, ok, man kann die Knöpfe drücken, das sieht nicht so aus, als könnte
man die drücken, streamst du über NVM, ja, ja, mache ich, sonst würde es ja noch, sonst
hätte ich ja CPU-Lust auf Doom, was mir, guck mal, wie das ruckelt, was mir auch ein bisschen
abgeht ist, dass Infanterie-Gameplay ein bisschen zu hart detached ist von Infanterie-Gameplay,
also, nein, also Vehikel-Gameplay ein bisschen zu hart detached ist von Infanterie-Gameplay,
ich meine, guck mal, hier gehts übelst ab in der Luft, aber es muss, es kehrt mich nicht,
es interessiert mich einfach nicht, es muss mich einfach nicht jucken, ist da jemand gelandet
gerade, häh, häh, hier ist doch eindeutig gerade jemand gelandet, ist das eine andere
Version, die du vorher spielen könntest, also ich würde sagen, oh, hier kommt ein, guck
mal, guck mal, guck mal, das ist so OP, niemand kann hier oben hin, niemand kann hier oben
hin, aber ich kann einfach oben hinstelzen, hier sitzt jetzt gleich einer, bam, nee, das
war schon down, glaubt ihr mir, dass das OP as fuck ist, pass auf, Snipe, Snipe got XX,
ey, das war hit, habt ihr das gesehen, das hat er aber nicht, der ist nicht gestorben,
Snipe got XX am Shut, hier, ich seh nix, wo ist denn überhaupt was, rekt, komm mal, jetzt
hab ich einen Medipack, seht ihr, wie OP das ist, ich hab Medipack dabei, ich kann mich
aufs Dach crappeln, er schreckt mich nicht so, und ich hab nen Medipack, Moment, XX Snipe
got muss wieder ans Start kommen, wo sind wir, ich seh nix, XX HD, XX HD, nee, oh hier, sag
mal, kann das sein, dass die Gegner massiv weggefickt werden gerade, das fängt übrigens,
das fängt übrigens auch sogar Sturzschaden ab, naja, also so, oh, oh, oh, da kommt was,
so begeistert ich am Anfang war, als ich das gespielt hab, das war so der initiale Hype,
das hat schon, das hat wirklich harte Schwächen, crappt der oder ist, nee, also aktuell hat
es wirklich harte Schwächen, hier ist einer drinnen oder, guck mal, guck mal, guck mal
Leute, easy, easy Mode, da oben ist er, auf dem Dach, schreckt, das Problem ist, du bist
nicht sicher, normalerweise musst, normalerweise musst du dir das erarbeiten, so ne Posi, und
bist dann auch relativ safe, das Problem ist, hier kann jeder da hergelaufene Typ sich rauf
und macht er auch, also das ist das OP as fuck auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen
Seite auch irgendwie dumm, achja und das Wetter nervt mich auch, also wenn ich einen Custom
Server machen kann, schalte ich das Wetter ab, hier ist irgendwo einer, ihr seht Visibility
der Gegner, nicht gegeben, hier ist einer, man weiß nicht wo, man sieht nichts, man kann
nicht gescheit spotten, irgendwo hier, da, so, man weiß es nicht, um nicht zu sagen,
man hat absolut keinen Plan, irgendwo hier ist er, und ich werde jetzt gleich von der
anderen Seite wahrscheinlich Hops genommen, da ist er, guckt hier, huge, huge aim, huge
aim, und jetzt bin ich weg, oh man, er hat mich gesniped auch noch, der Dude, übrigens,
ich hab ja mal im Video gesagt, dass das mit Spider and Prey nicht so gut funktioniert,
es geht, es geht, man muss ganz leicht, ganz leicht haben, dann geht das, da muss ich mich
selbst dran, hier ist doch einer, also ohne Scheiß, ihr seht es, Visibility, Visibility
0, da, du siehst ihn nicht, habt ihr, jetzt mal ernsthaft, habt ihr diesen Dude gesehen,
hier hinten, hier hinten ist wieder einer, du siehst ihn nicht, guck und jetzt mach
ich OP, OP high ground, lull, das ist so OP, das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu
sagen soll, dieses Movement ist einfach wirklich, ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, das
ist so, das ist so, wie wenn die in Battlefield 3 dem OP Assault mit M16 und so, irgendwie
ein Jetpack gegeben hätten oder so, by the way, hier ist einer, ich seh ihn nicht, und
er rockelt, oder ist er jetzt tot, man weiß, ja er ist tot, what the fuck, ich seh ihn
nicht, ich seh ihn nicht, wo ist er, wo ist er, du siehst die Gegner nicht, Visibility
ist wirklich hier, das macht mich fertig, ich hab gestern, ich hab, ich hab zwei Zentimeter
vor den Gegnern gestanden, jaja, picked you up, zwei Zentimeter vor den Gegnern gestanden,
und by the way, ich kann mich jetzt natürlich noch heilen, und du siehst ihn nicht, du
siehst ihn einfach nicht, das hat schon, das hat wirklich schon seine Probleme, das
hat seine Probleme, ok, eventuell Brille aufsetzen, null, guck mal hier, Achtung, Achtung, wuhu,
bringt übrigens gar nichts sich da dran, sich da dran zu stellsen, du findest es gut,
dass man Gegner suchen muss, also ich hab nix dagegen, weil man hinten ist in nem Busch,
aber das Problem ist, dass hier alles so grau in grau ist, du siehst, also selbst wenn du
ein Gegner siehst, wenn ich ein Gegner direkt im Fahnenkreuz hab, so wie den hier, oh fuck,
dann ist ok, aber sobald der durch den Busch läuft, du verlierst komplettes Tracking,
zumal die Gegner auch teilweise springen, also ich mein jetzt nicht slime, die stottern
so, dass du teilweise gar nicht genau weißt, was Sache ist, und man sieht nicht wo Medics
sind, also ich weiß, kommt einer mich ratzen oder nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht, ich release
mal, eventuell rennt jetzt einer voll auf mich zu, und ich wusste es nicht, das müssen
wir hier mal schnell hin und defenden, so, wir können das jetzt, guck mal auf dem Dach,
da stellst du es schon, wir machen jetzt Easy Mode, wir hoffen, dass der uns nicht sieht,
pass mal auf, pass mal auf, wir hoffen, dass der uns nicht sieht, und jetzt klappt es nicht,
und jetzt ist unter mir einer, der es aber zum Glück nicht checkt, ah fuck, aber habt
ihr gesehen, wie OP das ist, hätte der mich hier oben nicht von der Seite gestälzt, ich
hätte da jetzt 5 Leute gebashed unten, es muss Spotten geben, ohne Spotten klappt das
jetzt nicht funktionieren, ohne Spotting wird das, ich hab übrigens keine Ahnung, dass
der da war, das war einfach nur, oh das ist ein, Achtung in der Mitte kommt jetzt einer,
oder auch nicht, what the, what, hier ist einer, ach das ist der Doc, oder wie auch immer das
Ding heißt, was pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Massive Skill Play, ne, aber
nicht, ich wusste nicht, was ich sagen soll, mir ist nichts sinnvolles eingefallen, die
Gegner werden gerade übelst Hops genommen, Fahrzeughandling ist auch, fühlt sich voll
an wie Halo, hat einer von euch Halo 3, die letzte Mission mal gespielt, das fühlt sich
an, wie so ein Warhawk zu fahren in Halo, hier, du kannst das Ding wohl richtig steuern,
das ist schwammig, guckt euch das mal an, ich fahr da jetzt rein, pass mal auf, wir machen
jetzt Massive, so und jetzt gehen wir an die Gun, ach der ist, der Dude ist an der Gun,
ja klar, ja klar, ja klar, was ist deine Meinung, erste Meinung zur Beta, macht Spaß, hat aber
echt viele Probleme, also nichts was man nicht fixen kann, muss man ja mal klar sagen, aber
es hat schon, es hat schon richtige Probleme, das Game, also Webster ist so OP, du kannst
nichts anderes spielen, du musst Webster spielen, das ist, das geht einfach sonst nicht, hier
ist übrigens einer, der Captured, ich mein, jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute, will wirklich jemand
sagen, das ist nicht OP, dass ich hier hoch kann, niemand kann das contesten, außer er
spielt selbst Webster, versteht ihr, und ich kann mich heilen, und ich kann mich heilen,
leider ist die Pose halt auch nicht selbst, weil die auch hier hoch kommen, ahja, Surfer
desynchten auch mal ganz gerne, Surfer desynchten auch, also der ist schon tot, obwohl du nicht
denkst, dass er tot ist, und umgedreht und so, ist das nicht OP, ist das nicht OP, fuck,
guckt euch das mal an, ich krieg mich gar nicht mal ein, ich krieg mich echt nicht ein,
das muss genervt werden, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich hab Mini Packs, ich hab nen Crappling
Hook, ich hab alles, und wisst ihr was noch viel schlimmer ist, ich bin über jede Range
gut, ich kann einfach ne ACOG drauf machen, und jetzt den Dude dahinten bashen, oder der
mich, na gut, ich hab nicht unendlich Muni, ja das stimmt, aber eben Squad, also das ist
krass, das ist mega krass, guck mal 23, ich hab nichts gemacht, ich bin einfach reingejoined,
hab mich sinnlos aufs Dach Crappling Hooked, und bashen Leute, easy, ich mein, unser Team
hat auch dominatet, das ist ja sicher, dass es irgendwie an mir liegen würde, großartig,
aber trotzdem, so, da sind sie, wir stellen uns jetzt, also man stellt sich jetzt in den
Wald, wenn die mich nicht vorher bashen, wir stellen uns jetzt in den Wald, weil niemand
sieht mich im Wald, oh fuck, 27, ne, das sieht man noch gar nicht, oder, Q's, ja morgen
können wir spielen, ach rechts oben, seht ihr mal Leute, ich blick da selbst nicht so
genau durch, richtig gescheites Scoreboard gibt es auch nicht, da musste es Escape drücken
ins Settings Menü, oder in das, nicht Settings Menü, in das Pausemenü, also jetzt mal ernsthaft,
es macht übel Spaß, es macht übel Spaß, aber es ist, also das ist ja auch nichts, was
auf Dauer Spaß macht, das macht jetzt mal übel Spaß, weil es halt so easy ist zu bashen,
Bots, ab morgen ist Open Beta, Bots ist die bescheuertste Erfindung aller Zeiten, ich
hatte gestern ein Match, da haben wir auch so dominatet wie eben die Runde, sind die Leute
gequittet, ich habe am Ende irgendwie noch 10 Bots gekillt oder so, weil nix mal da war,
das Switch, hä, hat mich das jetzt rausgeschmissen, ne, das Menü wo du switchst zwischen den Attachments
ist auch doof, das wäre viel besser über den Hots Key, dass er die Specialist vergisst,
das werden sie auf jeden Fall noch fixen, aber ihr müsst euch das mal auf der Zuge zergehen,
ich hab den, ich hab den, den Specialist mit der Abstand, opesten Mobility, Movement, ich
kann mich selbst heilen, ich krieg die besten Waffen im Game, hab sogar noch Kanaden dabei,
also das ist echt, asser Shit, ja Bots verstehe ich auch nicht, Gegner halten halt durch
den Server D-Sync auch unterschiedlich viel aus, ich kann euch das übrigens mal mit den
Attachments zeigen, wenn ich Glück hab, kriegt es unser Helistelser noch hin, wenn ich Pech
habe dann nicht, hab ja gehofft ich kann hier vielleicht irgendwie rein, weil die Rakete
macht am meisten Spaß da zu spielen, mit dem Geländer und dann hochkrabbeln, vielleicht
wenn der das einnimmt ist cool, dann kann ich hier rein spawnen, dann gibt es hier gleich
oben richtig Raketen, Raketenstells, das macht, das macht immer am meisten Spaß auf der Map,
ja das alte Klassen System, es ist ja gar kein so großer Unterschied, nur dass du jetzt
noch die Specialist Gadgets dabei hast, guck dich die Range an, so also Attachments, meine
Tastatur, meine Tastatur hat einfach sein RGB ausgeschaltet gerade, hat Battlefield RGB
Integration oder, also guck mal, du kannst hier die Visiere machen, das ist ok, du kannst
aber auch das Handling verbessern, on the fly, was hab ich gestern immer gespielt, Close
Quarters und Griff, so und dann verzieht das Ding noch nicht mal, guck mal, ich hab ja
gestern gesagt Spray and Pray geht nicht mehr, aber Spray and Pray, gar kein Ding, wenn man
die richtigen Sachen drauf hatte, sprühen und beten Jungs, sprühen und beten, übrigens
merkt ihr auch, dass das Vehicle Gameplay, wenn ich Glück hab, wenn ich Glück hab, komm
ich darüber, total detached ist von dem was auf dem Boden passiert, das juckt mich nicht,
hier fahren Panzer rum, hier fliegen Helis rum, ist egal, ist egal, einfach weiter rennen,
easy, easy, der da, nee hier, hier, nee hier, oder hier, hier, hier, hier, hier, hier,
nee hier, hier, nee hier, oder hier, hier, oh nee Open Field, sucked, jetzt werden wir
gesniped, komm mal hier, die Schneiber, Schneiber, Schneiber duken schon auf mich, aber ich kann
mich heilen, das ist so krass, ok.
Guck mal habt ihr den B-Sync gesehen, ich war schon längst fertig schießen, jetzt switcht
einfach auf ein anderes visier was der herr und es ruckelt wieder ok den holen wir jetzt
nein von der seite gebashed so und ich weiß halt nicht ob jetzt hier jemand kommt da
ist zum beispiel einer der könnte mich ressen macht er wahrscheinlich nicht weil er gebashed
wird ich will es einfach hitrecke ist auch nicht vorhanden ja ja das ist teilweise schon
echt hart und weil es so schwer ist von a nach b zu kommen ich will gar nicht hier hinten spawnen
ehrlich gesagt was danke game weil du dann von da nicht richtig weg kommst das habe ich noch nie
ausprobiert erinnert mich ein bisschen an warzone nur nur 3000 mal länger oder
oben da oben stellten sie runter wenn es gebashed
da mal fliegt er liegt ist das cheater stellt am start ne oder das ist
das ist einfach nur back
ich würde mich nicht wundern wenn ich schon irgendwelches cheater kram am start ist so
ich ich ich kill mich einfach man weiß nicht ob man gerätst wird und heli kriegst du auch
überhaupt nicht richtig mit also normalerweise hast du ja immer gehört wo der heli ist du
kannst anhand des sounds easy einschätzen und aber hier ist es so du hörst den heli
nicht und auf einmal macht es blub und du bist tot
bei der wege sind gegner um mich drum herum und man sieht sie nicht
ja ja ist gut lasst mich in ruhe
ich stelle mich ein bisschen weiter außen rum also im busch ist man ja eh safe dass
sie da ist man ja an an detect was sind das ist das
was ist das
oh hier ist was
pass mal auf ich sehe nichts ich sehe nichts
hab den ich hab den nicht gesehen alter ich habe ihn nicht gesehen der war direkt vor
meinem scope
ich meine der fuck
pass auf wenn hier im busch steht ich sehe den nicht wenn er im busch steht
hier sind welche ich hab sie ja genau gesehen
ok mein dude rennt vor
deine meinung bisher
im prinzip das was ich immer im letzten video gesagt habe
aber das spiel hat schon harte probleme
es macht mega spaß aber es ist also es ist schon einiges nicht so richtig durchdacht
ich habe keine muni mehr ich brauche muni haben sie in kia so vor früher gesagt
solltest mal auf low stellen das ist low das ist alles low
habt ihr mal wieder gesehen wie op der grappling hook ist
einfach munitions aufsatz wechseln wirklich nee oder
nee wenn das funktioniert auf die idee bin ich ja noch gar nicht bekommen
ich meine ich habe es für möglich gehalten das sagt schon alles aus oder
dass ich das allein schon für möglich gehalten habe sagt alles aus
was ist denn hier los was ist denn hier los
was ist denn hier los was ist denn hier los was ist denn hier los
sorry falls ich irgendwelche host oder so übersehen hab keine absicht bin grad zu
das war zu früh das war zu früh
das ist normal weil halt webster stellt von allem
da unten ist was das einfach einfach verschwunden ich habe den tun nicht gesehen da hinten
ich weiß dass man mit zählen falschen wieder lösen kann das problem ist dass ich überhaupt
nicht drinne habe wie lang das ding brauche ich bin gestern schon ein paar mal sinnlos
ja ist ja gut ja gut alter lasst mich spawnen man ich glaube diese runde ist es umgedreht
diese runde kriegen wir auf den sack wo sieht man seine tode noch mal leute wo stehen seine
ach hier oben ja ach da ja ich habe es gesehen ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen 018 der
kd katnup geht gut hallo was geht hier
guckt euch die fucking range an
ja klar kann ich guck mal hier noch besser wird noch besser von oben kann man reinschießen
oh god jetzt weiß hier out flanking moves und dann in your face man
jetzt drücken sie aber schon hart hier rein wir müssen hier oben sparen gibt es ja nichts
anderes ach ja was mich auch irritiert ist dass die dass die dass die map richtung nicht
die sporn richtung ist
ammo wieder wechseln du hast den neuen oh guck mal
das erste mal dass ich gerätzt werde wahrscheinlich habe ich sogar noch meine waffe aufgehoben
das passiert öfters mal
geets
Mini-Pack
Da kommt der nächste
Es war kein Gegner, okay, ah, lass mich in Ruhe
Mit F kann man das Scope kennen, erinnern. Tatsächlich, ich dachte F ist Nahkampf
F ist Nahkampf, Lull. Wieso alle, wieso alle schibaden des Todes hier. Hab ich überhaupt das Richtige ausgewählt? Warte mal, kann nix ändern mit F.
Ah, das war einfach mal. Achtung hier, war das Flank-Action hier hintenrum. Ja, das war das richtige Timing.
Tja, wenn man jetzt was sehen würde, wär halt ein massivster Pogchamp.
So, easy Mode zum Captchern, wenn man rankommt. Passt mal auf, ich zeig euch easy Mode zum Captchern, wenn ich rankomme und nicht von der Seite gestellt werde. Easy Mode zum Captchern.
Einfach aufs Dach, einfach aufs Dach stellst und pass auf, riesen Range nutzen, Dach stellst, Gegner nicht sehen, dann nicht checken, dass es einer von mir ist.
Dann aus irgendwelchen Gründen den Gegner nicht killen, doch noch bashen, dann angeschossen werden, nicht wissen von wo und dann wegsliden und sich heilen, das ist so OP.
So OP aufs Dach, so OP, guckt es euch an, das ist einfach so krass. Oh ne, ok Moment, Magazin wechseln, jetzt gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert. Jetzt gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert.
What? Was? Five Head Time. Five Head.
Hey Six Kopf ist das eigentlich, der Fünfer reicht dafür schon nicht mehr. Siebener Kopf Mann. Wo sind die eigentlich? Ach da unten.
Bashen Alter, Bashen, Bashen, Bashen, Bashen. Wir brauchen Nades, Nades schmeißen. Oh fuck, das war nicht auch. Wie es alle sliden, alle schon schön am sliden.
Oh hier Spawnen, go, go, go, go. Das ist ja OP as fuck, das wusste ich noch gar nicht. Das ist ja brutal. Ok hier kommt ihr nicht raus, ich bech euch einfach sobald ihr da raus kommt.
Wenn ich nicht gesniped werde von irgendwo, pass mal auf da hinten ist was. Naja, der auf dem Dach, ist der auch, nee. Oh, vielleicht habe ich Glück, vielleicht kann ich.
Lull. Schreckt. Tyrannosaurus schreckt. Achtung, Achtung. Wow, wow. Es sind ja 80 Leute drin. Es ist ja komplett dicht das Teil.
Es ist ja komplett voll. Da hätte ich mal gewartet und reingestellt, da hätte ich dann auch 10 Stück kölen können oder so.
Äh, nee, nee, nee, nee, wir gehen hier direkt, direkt Hotzone wieder rein. Ok, Granaten stellts, Granaten stellts. Bäm. Hä, der wurde übrigens spät markiert.
Ah, übrigens wieder Sturm am Start. Sind das Boards? Nee, das sind echt Dachteformen. Alter, da unten. Was? Oh fuck, jetzt kommen sie raus. Jetzt muss ich hier stellen. Ah nee, meine Leute sind schon noch da, oder?
Alter, was geht hier unten? Oh, von hinten, von hinten stellts sich was an. Easy, easy. Pass auf, der will mich auch outflanken, aber das geht nicht.
Hier wird nicht outgeflankt. Wenn hier einer outflankstellts auf dem Dach macht, dann bin ich das. Oh, die haben den Crabling-Hulk-Cooldown, glaube ich, ein bisschen höher gemacht.
Wobei, haben sie nicht, ich hab nix gesagt.
Wisst ihr, es macht mega Bock, aber es hat halt echt schon ziemliche Floss zu empfehlen. Zum Beispiel, dass außer Webster fast alle Specialist useless sind. Ich mein, was willst du machen gegen solche Movement-OP-Geschichten?
Nix machst du da. Da machst du nix.
Okay, wir stellts jetzt einfach rüber, easy. Will uns schon keiner bashen, einfach rüber stellts.
Ja, nö, nö, nö, nö. Lohnt sich da für ne Midi-Pack, da lohnt sich keine Midi-Pack für.
Ja, ja, ist gut. Easy. Oh, oh, Schneiber, Schneiber stellts. Ja, ja.
Zick, zack, Achtung. Dodge-Action. Ah, jetzt startet die Rakete. Wenn wir Glück haben, startet die Rakete. Ich glaub, das habt ihr noch nicht gesehen. Also nicht bei mir.
Ich könnte dich retzen, aber ich hab Schiss. Ich sag euch, das Movement, das ist echt krass.
Okay, ich hab ein Problem. Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt die Stellts-Action hier. Next, please.
Ich muss da irgendwie ran stelltsen jetzt. Ihr seht übrigens, wie schnell die Life-Wreck geht. Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell. Nein.
Nein. Next. Okay, ich heil mich schon mal, weil hier oben gucken sie runter, garantiert. Ja, ja, so nicht.
Oh, ich hab leider kein Capture an. Okay, Achtung, Achtung. Massive Stellts-Action. Massive Stellts. No, verschissen. Das Stellts-Master hat's verkackt.
Ich will das, die Rakete. Alter, ich brauch meinen Grappling-Hook. Ich will, dass ihr die Rakete seht. So, wie war das jetzt? Einfach Mac wechseln?
Alter, das ist so OP. Ich fasse es nicht. Das ist so OP. Okay, ich fasse zusammen. Wir haben die besten Waffen, die beste Range, die beste Mobility.
Wir können Leute wiederbeleben und wir haben unendlich Ammo. Und wir haben unendlich Ammo.
Oh. Three-Head. Low-Brain, Alter. Low-Brain. Low-Brain. Ich hab den, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gesehen habt, ich hab den Fallschirm noch gezogen, aber hat nicht gereicht.
Hat nicht gereicht. Low-Brain. Streamer Small-Brain.
Streamer Small-Brain. Es ist so OP. Es ist... Leute, ich krieg mich nicht mehr ein. Ich krieg mich nicht mehr ein.
Okay. Nein. Nein. Oh. Oh. Oh. Ich weiß nicht, von wo. Grappling-Hook an die Rakete. Funktioniert nicht. Funktioniert nicht.
Funktioniert nicht. Nein, das ist das gleiche. Der einzige Unterschied zwischen Beta und... Oh, die Rakete startet. Leute, Leute. Passt auf hier. Rakete. Guckt. Guckt hier. Rakete. Ja. Da. Da ist sie.
SpaceX-Test. Bezos fliegt ins Weltall. Wobei Bezos ist ja glaube ich eher gerade in New World aktiv.
Na mal, hier hinten ist doch angeblich ein Gegner, oder? Wo ist der denn? Okay. Weiß nicht, wo. Irgend... Ah, da. Die hieß sterben. Oh. What? Alter, die sind as fuck. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Oder? Nee, das war ein Assist nur. Das war glaube ich nur ein Assist. Weil ansonsten wär das ja wirklich... Die Sync of Doom gewesen. Guck mal, da unten ist einer. Den ratzen wir jetzt. Achtung. Rats. Stell's.
Den hab ich nicht gesehen. Den hab ich wirklich nicht gesehen.
Boomer-Augen. Genau. Richtig. Boomer-Eis. Okay, jetzt können sie von... Aber es desync schon krass.
Ah. Nice. Ich hab ein Problem. Ich hab kein Leben. Du musst jetzt einfach gucken, dass hier irgendeiner reinstellt und mich nicht basht.
Übrigens, der Respawn hab ich euch ja gar nicht erzählt. Der Respawn ist auch teilweise ziemlich unfair. Du respawnst wirklich hinter Leuten.
Ah. Okay. What is happening? Wo ist hier was? Ich seh nix. Ich seh nix, ich seh nix. Ah, Midi-Pack. Sehr gut. Excellent.
Hallo. Lass mich please rein. Oh, das ist auch krass. Oh, das ist nice OP-Pose. Wir campen uns jetzt hier einfach ab. Da hinten ist ein Gegner.
Ich camp mich jetzt hier einfach rein. So. Nein, nein, bleib oben. Camp FPS, ja. Der ist verdammt.
Okay. Wir benutzen mal das Feature. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Oh, nee. Ah. Eats, Eats, Eats.
Macht ihr das mehr Spaß als Battlefield 5? Ja. Ich hab Battlefield 5 aber auch so gut wie nicht gespielt.
Dauern die Runden länger? Geht so. Es nimmt sich eigentlich nicht viel.
Also wenn man das mal vergleicht mit Battlefield 3 und sagen wir mal so ne Grand Bazaar Runde auf nem ordentlichen Server mit normaler sinnvoller Ticketanzahl.
Ja. Das ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinnsunterschied. Ich mein man kann es jetzt nicht mit irgendwelchen 50.000% Metro-Tickets vergleichen oder so.
Bist du mit deinen FPS zufrieden? Nö. Es ruckelt wie Sau zwischendurch. Ihr seht es ja wahrscheinlich auch im Stream teilweise.
Immer wenn es oben gelb oder rot wird dann stockt es komplett und ansonsten bricht es halt auch zwischendurch ganz schön ein.
Ach guck mal ich bin rausgeflogen da guck ich jetzt mal kurz in den Chat. Denk grad schreibt Ed Wublos dabei sonst seh ich sie aber im Durchgucken nicht.
Hatten wir grad schon. Jemand der Battlefield 3 liebt und Battlefield 4 gut findet wird er das neue Battlefield. Ah nee geht doch weiter.
Das hängt ganz davon ab ob sie das noch auf die Reihe kriegen. Es spielt sich schon anders. Sowohl vom Waffenhändling das ist bisschen weg vom Battlefield 3 jetzt nicht so krass.
Das ist im Prinzip von der Größe so ne Battle Royale Map. Nur das sich nichts verkleinert und das halt alles permanent aktuell bleibt.
Und was also eine Sache die mir halt bei der Map nicht gefällt ist erstens dass sie irgendwie ziemlich uninspiriert ist.
Ist jetzt nicht so wow demer wenn Peek Faktor ja. Das Problem ist bei der Map dass du entweder ihr seht es ja eigentlich auch im Spawn Bildschirm.
Es ist entweder Clusterfuck oder nichts los. So ein Zwischending gibt es nicht. Clusterfuck oder nichts los. Was doof ist.
Oh noobtube.
Hä?
Hier los. Ach das ist übrigens kacke hier kommt man nicht mehr raus. Weitere Grund warum man Webster spielen sollte.
Das ist übrigens der Halo Tunnel. Ich hoffe dass ich als Callout Halo Tunnel durchsetze.
Das ist ich zeige es euch mal. Das ist original der Halo Tunnel. Und wenn ihr mit einem Jeep durchfahrt mit der Halo Fahrphysik.
Das ist original Halo 3 Tunnel. Also jeder der Halo 3 gespielt hat muss mir recht geben das ist der Halo Tunnel.
Ich hoffe das setzt sich als Callout durch. Und gerade wenn man mit der neuen Fahrzeugphysik hier durch fährt das fühlt sich auch an wie Halo 3.
Übrigens wisst ihr was woran ich merke dass ich richtig Boomer bin mittlerweile. Wenn ich zwei Stunden gespielt habe kommt mir das vor wie früher acht.
Ich kann so ein Game gar keine konzentriert keine zehn Stunden ab Tag mehr cryen. Das kriege ich gar nicht mehr hin.
Was ist hier los? Guck mal der sieht mich nicht mehr. Er sieht mich nicht. Er sieht mich nicht. Und jetzt oh.
Und er stirbt jetzt. Und ich würde gerne einen Medipack legen aber ich darf meinen. Wo ist mein Medipack?
Wo ist mein Medipack? Hab ich vergessen mein Medipack auszuwählen Leute? Hab ich vergessen mein Medipack auszurüsten?
Kann es sein? Hab ich mein Medipack nicht ausgerüstet? Ok ich werde mich mal wippen kurz und mein Medipack ausrüsten.
Oder was das war? Ey ich stürme jetzt einfach rüber easy.
Wisst ihr was cool wäre wenn man das Visier. Ah. Das funktioniert ja wirklich mit F. Das ist ja noch mehr OP.
Ich habe einen Red Dot, ein normales Visier. Ich habe einen Medipack. Ich kann Squad-Mates retzen.
Ich habe die beste Mobility in-Game. Gibt es irgendeinen Grund warum ich was anderes als Webster spielen sollte von irgendwas ein komplettes Leben lang?
Eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich nicht. Nope. Den Robo-Dog.
Ja die anderen Specialist sind alle schon ganz cool. Mit dem Unterschied dass nichts an den Grappling-Hook rankommt.
Deswegen musst du den Grappling-Hook spielen. Das ist einfach zu krass.
Das ist einfach zu krass. Ich habe keinen Medipack. Das sackt ziemlich.
Guckt euch mal auch die Range an. Seht ihr das?
3 Kilometer. Guck mal F. Die treffen zum Glück genauso schlecht wie ich.
Oh da kippt was. Honda-Side.
Kann man den Hook cancelen. Das muss ich noch ausprobieren. Das muss ich noch ausprobieren.
3 Assists. So jetzt erstmal das richtige ausrüsten. Ich glaube ich habe nämlich das ganze am Anfang der Runde vergessen. Guck mal. Ich habe einfach nichts.
Ich fürchte ich muss nochmal leaven und nochmal neu rein.
Ich glaube meine Klasse ist gebrocken.
Gucken wir mal.
Ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Ja scheint zu funktionieren. Okay gut.
Ich gucke mal ob man den Grappling-Hook abbrechen kann. Ja.
Das ist ja noch cooler. Da kannst du ja richtig nice Fake Mobility-Tricks machen.
Dahinten steht übrigens einer. Nee. Sieht nur so aus. Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Eigentlich müsste hier ein Sektor angezeigt werden. Weil...
Tja hätten wir jetzt mal eine Map die ich öffnen kann.
Die Range ich fasse ich komme einfach nicht drauf klar wie OP das ist.
Oh wow. Warum wird der als grün angezeigt? Der ist nicht grün.
Das ist ein Gegner. Ich habe dumm nachgeladen. Kann ja keiner wissen dass der hier runtergestellt kommt.
Der Madcock.
Wie immer Grappling-Hook macht jedes Spiel besser. Eigentlich nicht. Es macht Bock.
Das Problem ist nur das ist so krass OP. Du darfst nichts anderes spielen.
Und ihr seht übrigens es war hier noch nichts los. Jetzt ist hier keine Ahnung gespawnt halb China.
Und halb China hat den Punkt secured. China-Chinesen am Start.
Ich glaube übrigens ganz oben ist einer. Passt mal auf ich teste jetzt Matrix 17 ob das funktioniert.
Wow. Six Head Move.
Übrigens Gegner hören tut man auch nicht.
Richtig Six Head Move. Moment ich muss auf die Rakete. Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Kann man auf die Rakete drauf? Wo geht es hier rauf? Kann man auf die Rakete?
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Kann man auf die Rakete?
Alter bin ich bald mal oben.
Okay kann man kann man auf die Rakete?
So schon mal nicht.
Sehr realistischer Move. So ist das. So macht man das in echt auch übrigens.
Falls ihr euch gefragt habt wie die normalerweise so was runter kommen dann so.
Warum ist das warum ist das ein HQ und das hier ist kein Sektor?
Hä? Warum ist das 87 hier HQ? Ich checke es nicht.
Ich kann es hier nicht rüber. Denke Anzeigefehler. Wahrscheinlich.
Das Spiel ist eh gerade übelst. Ich glaube ich gehe noch mal raus aus der Runde.
Eben mega verbugged. Es wird teilweise Sachen nicht angezeigt. Mein Loadout ist leer.
Guck mal hier sind 50 Gegner und ich kann nichts machen.
Ja irgendwann. Ich suche mir mal ein neues. Irgendwas ist da. Wie nennt man das? Scuffed heutzutage. Nee.
Kaputt. Wird es Rush geben? Das frage ich mich auch.
Die haben nichts dazu großartig gesagt.
Aber sie haben sich so davor gedrückt was zu sagen, dass ich fast vermute. Nein.
Kannst du dich mit dem Haken hochziehen an einer Stelle Hauswand cancel und bevor du wieder auf den Boden dich neu hochziehen.
Ja wenn du genug Zeit hast. Dann kannst du dich mit dem Haken hochziehen.
An einer Stelle Hauswand cancel und bevor du wieder auf den Boden dich neu hochziehen. Ja wenn du genug Zeit hast den Hook zu reloaden bestimmt.
So hoffentlich geht es jetzt. Oh nein ich habe wieder nichts ausgerüstet.
Da speichert sich ja nichts. Ist das Kopf über oder bin ich Kopf über?
What the? Wow. Ich traue meinem Heliman nicht.
Es war gut meinem Heliman nicht zu trauen. Mein Heliman ist auch verreckt.
Ok was ist das hier, das hier, das hier, das, nein das.
Ich vertraue nie fremde Helimänner.
Aber warum? Was? Alles klar. Alles klar. Na klar.
So wir haben jetzt komplett falsch. Das ist auch was das mich nervt, dass der das sich nicht merkt.
Ok ja das passt. Gruppenpanda ist am Start.
Hier hin, hier will ich hin. Hier wird gebashed. Massive bashed ist hier angesagt.
So wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein bisschen was anderes von der Map an.
So das müssen wir erstmal kurz checken wo hier was abgeht.
Da oben hat gerade einer eine Kiste hingeschmissen. Das heißt da muss einer sein.
Deswegen sage ich euch. So bisschen Surroundings im Blick behalten ist immer gut.
Und weil in dem Game kann man sich nicht drauf erlangen. Du hörst nichts. Du hörst nichts.
Also du hörst keine Helis die über dich fliegen gerade und sonst was. Du hörst nichts.
Also du hörst keine Schritte, du hörst keine Fahrzeuge, du hörst nichts.
Achtung. Alter.
Da.
Wie viel ist das bis jetzt? Es macht übel Bock.
Es macht wirklich Bock aber das hat harte Probleme das Game.
Bin mal gespannt wie das zu Release ausgehen wird.
Soll ich denn hier spawnen? Ist ja nix.
Da ist Kacke zum rüberlaufen.
Da haben wir nix.
Da stellst du Leute wenn ich Glück habe erobern die das. Ah ein D1. Okay wir spawnen ein D1.
Alles klar.
Und gleich aufs Dach. Zack.
Oh da drüben sind 50 Gegner.
Gleich, gleich Dings hier mal.
Sind die da überhaupt?
Man sieht ja nix. Moment ich hab bloß 20 Schuss drinnen weil.
Ah weil weil Crap Ammo.
Jetzt.
Immer schön im Kreis runter.
So wir stellts jetzt mal hier durch den Tunnel.
Ich bin hier glaub ich noch nie durch den Tunnel gestellts. Ah der aimt ab.
Kommst du raus? Guck raus.
Guck raus. Gibt es eigentlich Cornerstells? Nee Cornerstells gibt es nicht.
Weiß ich ob da noch mehr sind.
Oh das war PP Guard. Das war PP Guard.
Also das einzige Scoreboard was es gibt ist das aber das ist kein Scoreboard weil da nix drin steht.
Und es buggt rum.
Irgendwie.
Das Spiel ruckelt und laggt zu schlimm trotz gut einfach. Yup.
Leider. Leider.
Sollen wir mal gucken ob wir irgendwas hier Tunnel machen können.
Ja klar geht es durch den Kopf durch.
Ich weiß nicht so.
Da ist eine Granate geflogen gerade.
What? What? What? What?
Das war der Heli. Leute das war der Heli. Man hat den Heli wieder nicht gehört.
Hä? Oh Gott dieser verbackte Schild man.
Ja klar ist alles durchgegangen.
Also Crabbling Hook ist wirklich OP. Am Anfang habe ich nicht getroffen aber danach ist es einfach durchgeflogen.
Den Fahrstuhl kenne ich. Der Fahrstuhl ist richtig kaputt.
So wir müssen mal wieder unsere OP Fähigkeiten ausnutzen. Hier läuft es gerade nicht gut.
Und wenn es nicht gut läuft wisst ihr was einfach aufs Dach Crabbling Hooken und alles Bashen.
So einfach ist es. Guck den da zum Beispiel.
Schreck sein Sohn alter. Schreck sein Sohn.
Hat sich ausgeschreckt. Der wurde geschreckt gerade.
Hast du schon mal was mit Aqua gemacht? Ich glaube du könntest schön über das Game ranten.
Äh ne. Ich habe auch keinen Kontakt zu ihm.
Wir haben uns im Skype von vor 50 Jahren aber Skype benutzt keiner mehr. Ich nicht. Er wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Rantet er auch über das Game? Ich habe von ihm was gesehen und er hat das voll abgefeiert.
Ich ja auch am Anfang aber das Game hat halt echt Probleme ne.
Also das ist im Kern ist es richtig gut. Also macht mega Bock.
Aber es hat schon krasse Probleme.
Ich habe irgendwas nicht richtig ausgerüstet. Bam.
Habe ich irgendwas nicht drauf? Doch eigentlich alles gut so.
Habe ich den Stock nicht drauf? Doch. Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Was ich finde ist übrigens auch sehr komisch mit den Gegnern die da halbtot rumliegen und die man da nicht killen kann.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Kennt ihr noch Snoop Dogg aus dem Battlefield 1 Gameplay?
Wo er einfach die ganze Zeit so gemacht hat.
Im Graben. Der hat nichts anderes gemacht.
Außer im Graben. So das ganze Game. Es ist das ganze Game im Graben rumgelaufen. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Das wäre jetzt auch ein bisschen OP.
So wir gucken. Nein. Nein. Lass mich in Ruhe. Lass mich.
Das ist übrigens auch so nett. Die spawnen hinter dir. Der ist nicht in Ruhe.
Der ist wahrscheinlich reingespawned oder so.
Kannst dich in dem Game null drauf verlassen wo was ist.
Bugs to Battlefield Release hat Tradition. Ja.
Ok komm. Volle Offensive. Bashen. Alter Bashen.
What the fuck.
Wo zum Teufel bin ich?
Doch. Ne. Keine Killcams.
Ach ich bin in diesem komischen Tunnel. Oh ne da will ich nicht rein. Ich will nicht in den Tunnel.
D1. Lass mich D1 spawnen. D1. D1. D1. D1.
Ok. Easy Dach. Easy Dach Bash. Easy Dach Bash.
Oh unter mir ist was.
Nein. Nein. Nein.
Irgendwo hier kommt jetzt gleich was. Achtung.
Ok.
Also ich gebe zu. Ich habe den teilweise nicht getroffen. Aber zwischendurch ist er durchgeflogen.
Ihr habt gesehen. Wie krass mir abgegangen sind die ersten zwei Runden.
Aber jetzt ist gerade nicht mehr. Es ist vorbei.
Jetzt hat es. Ich sage euch Leute.
Leute, ich hab's, ich hab's, jetzt kickt skill-based-matchmaking, jetzt ist vorbei, jetzt ist der Spaß, jetzt ist gelaufen der Spaß, ja.
So, hier müssen wir nicht hin.
Ja, komm.
Ja, ich hab den auch nicht richtig getroffen.
Das merke ich noch, ich hab halt keine Übung mehr, das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Es wird besser, ihr hättet mal sehen müssen, ihr hättet mal sehen müssen, wie krass ich verkackt habe am Anfang.
Also da hab ich, als ich versucht habe auf den zu aimen, am Anfang hab ich irgendwie so...
Vorgestern oder, nee, Montag, wo wir das Anspiel-Event haben.
Mittlerweile geht's schon wieder.
Weil manchmal geht's ja, manchmal, das war jetzt zum Beispiel clean, ja, dann kannst du nichts sagen.
Cleaner F.
Okay, wir stellten uns jetzt hier runter.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir hier durchkommen, aber easy.
Gegner hören ist ja eh nicht, passt, passt, ich kann's probieren.
Okay, hier unten ist auch gern, hier an der Ecke ist auch oftmals was.
Hier wird auch gerne gestellts an der Ecke.
Juhu.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, sollst du da nicht hin.
Okay, jetzt ist da, das Ganze hat sich doch jetzt schon ziemlich, ziemlich statisch entwickelt.
Wir müssen jetzt hier aufs Dach.
Guckt euch die Range an, mann, äh, nope, hallo, please, äh, ich muss hier weg, grappling und reloade, reloaden, please, reloaden, reloaden.
Sehr gut, excellent.
Wie ist das Ding aufs Dach gekommen? Wie ist das Auto aufs Dach gekommen?
Ja, okay, das ist weak.
Wie ist das Ding aufs Dach gekommen?
Wie ist das Auto aufs Dach gekommen?
Ja ok, das ist weak.
Das ist ja witzig.
Ich bleib jetzt hier einfach drin sitzen.
So, wenn ihr mir schon dieses Auto aufs Dach gestellt habt, ich kann hier nicht drin sitzen
bleiben.
Das ist Müll.
Muss bashen.
Alter.
Bashen, alter, bashen.
In den Busch, dann sieht er mich nicht.
In den Busch.
In den Busch stellst du.
Gucken, wo er ist.
Da ist er, da ist er, hier ist er.
F***.
Es sind drei Stück und das eine war der kacke Hund.
Oh bin ich schlecht, mann, guck mal, 3-7, mann, ersten Runden hier, 30, 35, bam und jetzt,
jetzt ist vorbei.
Ich sag jetzt, jetzt kickt er SBMM, was Schwachsinn ist, glaub ich nicht, das ist einfach Pech.
Du kannst ja nicht jede Runde übelst reinhauen.
So, wir kriegen diese Runde, es ist relativ ausgeglichen.
Wow, schön vorbei gesniped.
Alter, hier kann ich doch nicht runter, wenn ich hier runter gehe, das ist ja richtig bepeger.
Guck mal, wie offen das ist.
Ja, ich hör alles Low, alles Low Graphics.
Das ist hardcore Pepega, wie soll man denn hier durchkommen?
Da oben stellst du einen, hau noch rum.
Oh, die bashen wir jetzt, Leute, die werden jetzt gebasht.
Destroyed werden die jetzt, mit dem grappling hook von unten.
Die sind bestimmt noch da.
Lass meine, meine Gegner, Alter, lass zu die, mann, lass die.
Ah, jetzt hat die gebasht, ich fass, der hat die einfach gebasht.
Für Low sieht es echt gut aus, ja, aber es läuft für Low nicht gut.
Läuft nicht gut.
Ui.
Irgendwie reloadet der grappling hook auch inkonsistent, mal schnell, mal langsam, mal
schnell, Pepega, I need this, oh, next please, es ruckelt, fuck, fuck, meine Maus bewegt sich
immer richtig, what the fuck, null, was war denn das, jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen,
ok, die Runde gibt's neu, die Runde gibt's auf den Sack, meine Maus hat sich bewegt gerade,
die Maus, oh, geht gut Streamer, ja, ich weiß, oh nee, er sitzt wieder im Auto, das OP Auto,
wir bashen jetzt das OP Auto, ich hole jetzt das OP Auto, wo ist hier was, ah, von allen
Seiten, der Typ stells da auf dem Dach, ich sags euch, der macht Dachstells, alles weg,
ok, alles weg, oder FSR würde dem game gut, was ist FSR, was übrigens auch komisch ist,
dass manchmal Friendlies nicht als Friendlies angezeigt werden, oder zu spät, oder man sieht
es nicht, oder so, komisch, so, jetzt mal den Tunnel von der anderen Seite probieren,
was ist der Booster, mach mal die Battle frei, Battlefield 3, Jump Action, Achtung, na, das
funktioniert, das wär der Move des Jahrhunderts gewesen, hätte das mal funktioniert, hinter
uns geht voll was ab, so, wo sind sie, man sieht nix, ah, what, please, Gegner, wo seid
ihr, da, Alter, jetzt aber, meine Güte, ah, man hat die Abdeck-Abdeck-Spanner wirklich
kaum gehört, hätte der nicht geschossen, keine Chance, irgendwas, ok, wir stellts uns
jetzt mal auf andere Teile von der Map, ok, den hab ich ja wirklich nur, oh, links ist
was, links ist was, links ist was, was ist mit denen los, die liegen alle rum, die liegen
einfach alle rum, die liegen, what the hell, was geht hier grad ab, na gut, ich hab kein
Problem, wir nehmen hier alle rein rennen, ok, das kann man nicht aus der Hüfte schießen
in dem Game, direkt, Achtung, Achtung, pass mal auf, krieg 17, bam, neues Magazin, easy,
voll, das ist OOP, sag mal, das kann doch nicht sein, dass die das übersehen haben,
dass man sein Magazin einfach durch Magazinwechsel nachladen kann, das geht doch nicht, schön
die Noobs spawnen, ja, eben hab ich auf den Sack gekriegt, richtig, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt
grad wieder recovered, ich hab mir gestern voll Mühe gegeben mit, mit, mit Money Packs
einsammeln und so, dass man nicht out of Ammo geht und du siehst halt nix in dem Game, ich
mein ich brauch's nicht so OP wie Battlefield, wie Battlefield 3, dass ich irgendwie grob
in die Richtung spotter mit Q und erstmal die ganze Base gehighlightet wird, das muss
ja nicht sein, aber so ist auch nix, so ist auch nix, echt nicht, übrigens die sind jetzt
gar nicht hier, die spawnen gleich alle rein, das ist das nichts los zu Clusterfuck, guck
sobald wir hier anfangen, sobald wir hier anfangen, spawnen die hinter uns rein oder
auf der anderen, guck hier, schon der erste, die sind gespawned, die waren nicht hier,
die sind hier gespawned, was richtig pepega ist, hardcore pepega, was ist das, oh man
sieht auch nix, hab ich schonmal, hab ich schonmal erwähnt, dass man nix sieht, sind
nicht Max-Settings, den Max-FPS-Settings sind das, mit dem Unterschied, dass die FPS nicht
gut sind, da war doch was, oder, oder, Leute war da was, oder bin ich blind, Puma Augen,
oder war da was, sagt Chat, Chat, ich muss das wissen jetzt, Puma Augen, ok, nein, nein,
fuck man, ich hätte stehen bleiben sollen, wir sehen noch weniger, ja bei euch, bei euch
kommt noch dazu, guck mal, jetzt ist es grau und es ist in dieser komischen Naturumgebung,
bei euch pixelts jetzt, selbst mit 8 MBit, aber was soll ich machen, ich kanns noch höher
stellen, das dumme ist, wenn ichs noch höher stelle, da könnens weniger Leute gucken,
lass mich spawnsohren, let's go, the invalid spawnpoint, übrigens, das ist auch broken,
mit dem Tank, passt mal auf, wenn man nämlich in den Tank geht, wir spawnen jetzt hier,
wenn man in den Tank geht, dann ruckelt der Turm, du kannst den Turm gar nicht bedienen,
ok, jetzt brauch ich, ich brauch keinen Spawn Timer, eben hab ich Spawn Timer gebraucht,
jetzt brauch ich keinen Spawn Timer mehr, mal gucken, wo die anderen sind, immer erstmal
antäuschen, guck da, ich hab da nichts gecheckt, ich weiß nicht, wo da was ist, ah da ist so
ein komisches Car, was war das, das war bestimmt der Heli, übrigens, den Heli, den man nicht
gehört hat, sehr fair, sehr fair, sehr fair, ich bleib jetzt hier drunter stehen, ich bewege
mich nicht, übrigens, die Regentropfen sehen manchmal aus wie Spieler, was auch sehr irritierend
ist, das war 120mm Panzerbrechende Munition, oh Reds, Pog, Pog, Massive Pog, ok, das war
der Pog wieder, aber wisst ihr was krasses, das mit der Muni, das mit der Muni, das mit
der Muni ist so brutal, nein, nein, nein, nein, von wo, irgendwie den Heli, den du nicht hörst,
oh nee, ich glaub der wollt mich retzen, das ist auch doof, dass du nicht siehst, wenn
dich einer retzen will, ok hier ist was, schreckt, next peace, unter mir war was, ich hab's gesehen,
unter mir war einer, nee, das war meiner, ok, ich verpiss mich mal, GG Eats, links
neben mir war einer, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's ein Gegner war oder einer von meinen
Dudes, wahrscheinlich einer von meinen, wo kommen die Gegner eigentlich, genau so sieht
es mit der Rakete in der Echte auch aus, wo kommen die Gegners eigentlich her, spawnen
sie aus ihrem Heli, jawoll, wie gefällt dir die Beta bis jetzt, macht übel Spock, auch
wenn die Runde grad nicht so gut läuft, aber es ist teilweise schon richtiger OP, OP abfuck
am Start, wir gewinnen, easy, easy mode, win, easy wins, only easy wins heute, ich mein
Webster ist das OPste Kram, den sich ausgibt, ich kann retzen, ich hab die besten Waffen,
ich hab Mobility, die beste Mobility, ich hab alles, ich hab einfach alles, so, chat,
mal gucken, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, glaubst du es gibt nen Scoreboard, es
muss nen Scoreboard geben, also das Game ohne Scoreboard wär ja mal richtig abfuck, Eats,
long as we wait, now we jebaited, ja ich hoffe die jebaiten uns nicht, das wird schon laufen,
die Spawns sind übelst unfair zum größten Teil für die, die den Punkt defenden, du
gehst hin, es ist nichts da, du setzt dich rein, du wartest, captures, es spawnt alles
um dich drum herum, also ich mein wenn du defendest, während du captures, also es ist
der Punkt, ist still, du gehst rein, du sicherst das, es spawnt alles rum, neben dir, hinter
dir, unter dir, in your face, das ist aber auch das Problem mit 128 Spielern, was willst
du dagegen machen, die Map ist so offen, es gibt nichts wo du sagen könntest, hey hier
sind 3 Spawnpunkte oder so, die Map ist kaputt, die geht nicht, die Map ist broken, die geht
nicht, normalerweise solltest du M drücken, aber du kannst so viel M drücken wie du willst,
das funktioniert nicht, ohne die Map, ja das ist ein Problem, das ist wirklich ein Problem,
dass du halt keinen Überblick hast, deswegen rennt man hier auch teilweise total planlos
rum, du weißt halt nicht wo du hin musst, du kannst, das einzige wo du dich orientieren
kannst ist das hier, übrigens es sind auch zu wenig Fahrzeuge im Spawn, by the way, also
mit B kann man übrigens was rufen, was, wo ich ja nicht so genau gecheckt, ja lass mich
rein, lass mich rein Heli, Alter bleib hier, bleib hier, slide nicht über den Boden, lass
mich rein, was, was, wo bin ich denn da jetzt drin, bin ich Spotter oder so was, oh ich
bin Spotter, Massive, Massive Spotter, was ist G, jetzt hab ich G gedrückt, ich weiß
nicht was es macht, aber hauptsache mal G gedrückt, G in den Chat, ah guck mal, jetzt
kann man spotten, was, nichts bringt, wenn der jetzt hier drüber fliegt, jump ich da
oben drauf, guck mal die captchern schon, alter flieg ran, ich muss hier raus, jawoll, wie
in echt, so machen das die Spezialeinheiten halt, hallo, grappling hook, please, skippen,
was wenn es fertig ist, Pepega Aim, was ist Pepega Aim oder was war das gerade, lebt
der noch, nee, ah guck mal der hat mir ne Sniper hingelegt, das ist aber nett von dem, das
ist gar keine Sniper, da unten ist was, Achtung, Achtung, oh nee, fuck, kann ich das wegboxen,
jawoll, null W, die kann ich nicht hitten mit meinem Redhot so weit weg, guck mal hier,
ist alles voll, ich kann den nicht spotten, ich kann den nicht spotten, und den hab ich
Pepega, ich kann den nicht spotten, er ist down, alter ich Pepega die alle, aber es kommt
keiner hin, easy, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, ich hab nur ne Plan was hier abgeht,
ich seh grad, ich würde gern Gegner sehen, oh fast, oder auch nicht, hä, ach guck mal
ich hab ihn gebashed, bloß 50 xp, Spieler Pass, weil sowas in der Richtung, ja, also
ich find die Parallelen zu Passfinder Apex Technik sind schon deutlich zu erkennen, so
da will ich hin, da will ich hin, jawoll, bester Spawn alter, wow, kann es sein, dass
wir nichts haben außer diese Flag, zum größten Teil klappt das mit dem Aim mittlerweile wieder,
aber man merkt einfach, dass ich irgendwie, pass auf, pass auf, krieg 17, ok, hat nicht
funktioniert, doch, schreckt man, hat funktioniert, hier sind noch mehr, hier sind noch mehr,
schall, Gegner rum, der Crappy, hallo, darf ich das aufnehmen, please, game, ich möchte
gerne, ich möchte gerne mein Zeugs hier aufnehmen, das wäre nice, wenn das gehen würde, nein,
ok, hier ist nichts, so, wäre das nicht gut, wenn man die spotten kann, wäre das nicht
nice, das für einer, war das ein Bot, das war ein Bot, oder, das war ein Bot, ich hasse
es, dass in dem Spiel Bots sind, man, warum sind, warum sind da Bots in dem Spiel, was
soll das, niemand hat nach Bots gefragt, wirklich nicht, wirklich niemand hat nach Bots gefragt,
wer meinte Bots ist ne gute Idee, hallo, guck mal hier, Muni leer, zack, Muni voll, debated,
Muni leer, Muni voll, aber ich hab mich nachgeladen, ne, Muni wieder leer, Moment, das sind die
unterschiedlichen Munitypen oder was, ja, aber trotzdem, das ist doch, das ist doch
mega OP, ok, der stirbt nicht, das sind Bots, das sind einfach alle Bots, das sind alle Bots,
was ist denn das jetzt jetzt schon wieder, jetzt, aber, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, was machen
die anderen Makazine, weniger Rückstoß und schnellere Geschosse und so, aber ein bisschen
undurchdacht schon, dass du das switchen kannst, ich mein, die Muni, die man standardmäßig
dabei hat, ist eigentlich ok, weil ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so, also es ist ja jetzt,
wäre jetzt ja nicht so, als hättest du nicht eh schon alles, wenn du Webstar spielst mit
diesem Loadout, du brauchst ab und zu noch Muni, aber mit dem Muni switchen brauchst
du nur nicht mal Muni, brauchst nichts, brauchst einfach, destroy it, oder oben war was, ich
hab's gesehen, up we go, oder auch nicht, es fühlt sich schon ein bisschen Apexy an,
auch wenn ich das nie gespielt hab, länger als zwei Minuten, was war hier, was ist hier
los, was ist hier los, ich hab was gehört, es hat direkt neben mir geschossen und es
ist fast gestorben, laut meinem Sound, aber war dann nicht so, sag mal, haben die Gegner
nix mehr, ah da hinten, ok, ok, da gehen wir jetzt hin, ich, ach da ist was, let's
go, midi go, der Headshot Sound ist aber echt Gachibass, muss ich sagen, pass auf, pass
auf, prefire, hallo ich will Granaten, lass mich Granates werfen please, gibt's nicht,
oh gut, da nicht, so, let's capture mir das da hinten, ah da kommt was, ok, da hab ich
richtig PP-Gard, den Dude, Massive PP-Gard, wobei es finde ich auch schwer ist es zu treffen
in der Luft, weil die ja auch nicht so richtig smooth da Dingsen, sondern immer mal mit
Aussetzer-Frames zwischendurch, ok, jetzt bashen, alter, bashen, wo ist hier noch was,
hier ist noch was, 100 Pro ist hier noch was, hallo, ich bin Stuck, ich will nicht Stuck
sein, ist doch noch was, hier waren noch zwei, wo ist der denn hin, oh Moment, Muni ist leer,
weg, ha ha ha, das ist OP, ich flasche es nicht, warum, kann man eigentlich auch irgendwie
jetzt rumjumpen oder so, nee nicht so wirklich, das ist, ich hab keinen Bock ey, das sind
Bots man, hä, Leute ihr könnt mir nicht sagen, die Hit-Rack ist in Ordnung, das sind Bots,
warum spielen wir hier, nee das war jetzt wieder kein Bot, Bots sind dumm, Bots sind
richtig dumm, wer hat sich bei DICE gedacht, ach komm, das ist zwar ein Multiplayer-Spiel,
wir machen 128 Spieler, aber wenn es keine 128 Leute, dann machen wir Bots, ich möchte
eigentlich mein Midi-Pack haben, ah fuck, fuck, wo ist das, das ist richtig dumm mit
Bots, weiß nicht was man sich dabei gedacht hat, und vor allem, wer hat sich gedacht,
ja Bots oder, das macht bestimmt Spaß, Bots zu killen, ob sich das wirklich jemand gedacht
hat dort, ich kanns mir gar nicht vorstellen, da kommt was, Bot, jetzt merkst du direkt
am Movement, dass es ein Bot ist, Bot, Bot, Bot, ich geh da jetzt gleich raus, ich seh
so nicht ein, gegen Bots zu spielen die ganze Zeit, wir hatten doch vorher auch keine Bots,
übrigens morgen wird richtig nice, morgen wird proggers sag ich euch, morgen fangen
die ganzen Leute mit der Open Beta an, die noch nicht gespielt haben, da kann man richtig
destroyen, by the way man kriegt keinen Fallschaden dadurch, glaub ich zumindest, oder ich war
nicht hoch genug, ey was zum, wie oft er noch hinten, bitte bash mich Max, ja, wird
gemacht, wird gemacht, ist auch ein Bot, oh nee, wir bashen einfach Bots jetzt, easy,
ich hab wieder volle Money, Bots, Bots, ich bin gleich, ich sterbe gegen einen Bot, die
bewegen sich aber, come on, come on, bewegen sich auch so krass unattraktiv irgendwie,
die Hitbox vom Baum, ja die ist doch schon recht groß wie es aussieht, also ich geh
jetzt raus, ne, ok, das war jetzt ein Spieler, womit auch die Kugelteile was durchgeflogen,
also Bots ist wirklich eine sau dumme Idee, das macht überhaupt keinen Spaß, richtig
pepega, ey ich hab damit kein Problem wenn die Bots Server machen, ne, null, die sollen
natürlich Bots Server machen, wenn Leute sagen sie spielen lieber PvM oder keine Ahnung,
sie möchten zum üben Bots Server, ist vielleicht ja gar nicht schlecht Bots Server zu machen,
um zu sagen hey, um zu sagen hey ich will mal neue Loadout ausprobieren oder sowas,
warum nicht, aber doch please nicht in normalen, normalen Matches, come on, sah nur so aus,
ich könnte den retzen, ich sterbe aber wenn ich den retze, 100%, ich geh noch nicht runter,
gibt es jetzt nicht auf den High Ground, man könnte denken es ist ein Bot gewesen, es war
aber kein Bot, Achtung, Achtung von hinten, von hinten stellt es was, wow, dass man sich
auch noch selbst heilen kann, das ist so geil, was heißt so geil, eigentlich ist es überhaupt
nicht geil, du kannst nix anderes spielen, du kannst nix anderes spielen außer die Klasse
so in dem Loadout, so wir jumpen mal kurz rüber aufs andere Dach, irgendwo hier ist er, das
ist so, ey ich hab es 50 Billionen mal heute Abend gesagt, sorry Leute ich weiß, ich weiß,
aber es ist einfach OP AF, da könnt ihr mir nix sagen und noch ein Minipack und retzen,
irgendwo ist hier übrigens was, ich sehe nicht was, Achtung, andere Seite, neues Donkey
Kong hier, oh da ist noch einer, den ich nicht gespottet kriege, ah Mist, ohne all, Achtung,
wir switchen mal kurz Mac, mehr Schuss, hallo ich brauch Granaten, gibt's nicht, die sind
hier noch, sind da noch, ok wir switchen mal, ah da kommt was, da kommt was, ist das von
dem, desynced Server, Leute, ernst gemeinte Frage, habt ihr auch so Probleme, also ich
meine ihr habt sogar noch das Stream Encoding, aber man sieht's, also guckt mal, dieses Scenery
kann man richtig gut vergleichen mit Valparaiso, kennt ihr noch Valparaiso Bad Company 2, dieses
Scenery, total gut, da hast du die Gegner meilenweit gesehen und jetzt siehst du nix,
ich seh nix, einfach nicht, nicht, nix, ich seh alles, du bist alt, ok, ok, ok, das war
richtig, richtig schlecht, ich wollte hip fighten, ja, alter Heli, Flugzeugstelzer man, was geht
mit dem Flugzeugstelzer ab, achja, by the way, meine Muni ist leer, lull, ich switch mal
schnell, hab wieder volle, aber wir können auch mal die Waffe wechseln, dann hab ich auch
wieder volle Muni, 723, ok die Hälfte bots, die Hälfte bots, ok wir hauen jetzt hier
mal ab, wo können wir denn überhaupt hin, wird das hier, können wir das captchern,
ach guck mal, die bots sind am Start, die bots, das siehst du, wenn die so, jetzt sind
sie weg, die spawnen, die bots sind die spawnen, du siehst das immer wenn Spots sind, wenn
du drauf schießt und die bleiben so auf einschlag stehen und gucken in deine Richtung, die wissen
sofort wo du bist und mich hatte in der, in der Preview die ich gespielt hab, hat mich
ein Bot headshotted mit ner Granate um die Ecke, also der ist die Treppe hochgekommen
und ich hab gepiekt und ich hab so ne Brandgranate ins Gesicht bekommen von dem Bot innerhalb
von 20 Millisekunden, das war nice, also entweder sind die bots useless oder OP, je nachdem
was gerade angesagt ist, ok ich glaub wir müssen hier hin, jetzt sind wir wieder in
der Phase nix los und gleich sind wir in der Phase clusterfucked, übrigens, das sind
wieder bots oder, das sind doch, ne das sind keine bots, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
jump, jump, jump, jump, jump Reno, weg hier, weg hier, safe gehen, guck mal da unten werden
schon wieder gebashed, ich sehs hier, ich seh den ja auch net, ok jetzt muss ich switchen,
jetzt wissen sie wo ich bin, tank, hallo, hä, ach der ist downed, das ist auch nicht
so clever gemacht, dass du gedownte Gegner über range siehst als wären sie noch lebendig,
ich blicke hier nicht durch, das wird zu viel, wow, wow, ich slide jetzt in den Tunnel,
Achtung, Achtung, Pfeiffer, Pfeiffer time, wisst ihr was ich machen wollte, ich wollte
runter sliding in das Auto, ja in das Auto an die Gun, aber dann ist das Auto einfach
in die Luft geflogen, würdest du sagen die Probleme sind leicht zu fixen oder eher tief
gehende Probleme, naja, also dieses rumgeklitsche und so, das ist, das ist leicht zu fixen,
aber die, also die specialist, die specialist balance ist halt einfach krank, wie hoch
geht denn das überhaupt so, die specialist balance ist krank, darf, darf ich mal nen
coupling hook haben hier, du brauchst keinen anderen specialist außer webster zu spielen,
das schreckt, captain left hook, und mal gucken ob wir hier ganz hoch kommen, da hinten sind
übrigens 50.000 Gegner, das ist ziemlich sack dass ich hier sitze, die sehen mich da
ganz schön, ich muss da mal weiter ran, wir machen das anders, wir gehen hier über
die, wir gehen hier über das, das stealth Ding, bashen sie, ich hab nichts gesehen,
links, links, links, links, schreckt, next, wieder hoch, hinter mir, da ist der heli, der
wäre fast down gewesen, nice, assist, der wollte zipline stealth machen, schreckt, next,
oh, moment munition, muni, muni, ah ich muss hier einfach nur switchen, dann haben wir
da volle muni, perfekt, by the way, warum gehen die nicht ins auto, die sollen einfach
ins auto gehen und bashen, nein nein, du sollst nicht mich bashen, du sollst ins auto gehen
und bashen, wo ist mein midi pack, wo ist mein midi pack, ah hier, ich geh jetzt ins
auto, stellst mich jetzt ins auto und fahr den entgegen und baller alles weg, irgendwo
hier oben sind sie, falls noch was da, nein nein, oh halo style, die physik man, die physik,
die physik macht mich fertig, monkaS tier, monkaS tier, monkaS tier, monkaS tier, lass
mich geradeaus fahren, ich muss raus, oh fuck, ok ich muss raus, ja 44 bin ich zufrieden,
easy, was ist das für eine fahrphysik, grausame fahrphysik, schlimm, das wirkt mehr bouncy
als die dinger in halo, jetzt wisst ihr warum ich mit der bahn fahre, genau, halten die
unterschiedlichen specialist auch unterschiedlich viel aus, nein soweit ich weiß nicht es sei,
ich weiß nicht was sie da machen, dass sie vielleicht einen specialist bringen der panzerung
hat oder so, ich hab mal was gehört in der richtung aber ich bin mir da jetzt nicht mehr
sicher, das fände ich aber ziemlich schlecht wenn sie das machen würden, weil du gewöhnst
dich an so eine gewisse time to kill mit deiner waffe versus die gegner und wenn du nicht
genau weißt, ist es jetzt die hit rec die scheiße ist, der server desync oder dass der
gegner einfach 50 leben mehr hat, das ist ziemlich dumm, also ich hoffe sie lassen alle
specialist auf der gleichen stufe was leben angeht, du spielst 1080 ti, jeder kann panzerung
mitnehmen im vierten slot, das finde ich übrigens nicht gut falls das geht, ist ein bisschen
wie bed company 2, wo du entweder keramik armor oder wie hieß das magnum munition gespielt
hast, armorplate, ja ok, aber anstatt dem medipack nehme ich keine armorplate mit, ganz
bestimmt nicht, null, bin ich gerade in volles game gejoint, kann das sein, ich bin in game
gejoint, wo die gegner hard dominated wurden, wie viele waffen gibt es zurzeit, zwei assault
rifle, wir können gleich mal das andere assault rifle spielen, habe ich so gut wie noch nie
gespielt, mal gucken wie das ist, manchmal versteht man es nicht so gut, ok, wie gefällt
es dir overall, naja es macht spaß, aber ich wette, dass es mir nicht lange spaß macht
in der kombi, webster ist ops fuck, die map ist ziemlich uninspiriert, fahrzeugphysik
ist komplett beweger, also es macht spaß weil du halt hard bashen kannst, aber das
legt sich schnell, also bashen ist das was mit abstand, also gegner, weghauen ist das
was in games am meisten spaß macht aufdauer, aber es muss auch eine gewisse tiefe haben
und irgendwie, du musst dann auch wissen, dass du diese outplate hast, aktuell nimmst
du den grappling hook, läuft eine base, ziehst dich aufs dach und auf uns erstmal vier gegner
weg ohne dass sie was machen können, es ist irgendwie, ich mein noch macht es mega bock,
aber ich sag in der woche macht es keinen spaß mehr machen, außerdem gefällt mir
die map nicht gut, das muss ich einfach so sagen, die idee mag ja ganz cool sein so ein
space x mäßiges setting da zu bauen, aber die map ist ja da ist ja nix, es gibt auf
der map nix, es gibt die rakete, es gibt das hochhaus und es gibt hügel, fertig, die
map ist, also ganz ehrlich, die map versus, ich hab das erste mal dema vent gespielt,
dema vent peak gespielt, wir müssen, moment, das müssen wir schon machen, tier rating
bf maps, das machen wir noch bevor wir aufgehen, fällt mir gerade so ein, das wollte schon
man eine weile machen, also wir nehmen jetzt mal die andere waffe, gehen wir mal hier rein,
heli stellts, jawoll, aufs hochhaus, es zielt aber nicht dahin wo ich hinziele, kannst du
uns please hochfliegen, jawoll in the cop, alter in the cop, wow vertraue nicht an einem
heli flieger, ok tschüss und tschüss, und tschüss und tschüss, moment was hab ich
denn hier, was brauch ich denn, red dot, oh da hinten ist was gestellst, oh nee da unten
kommt was, achtung easy bash, easy bash, easy bash, wow wow wow die waffe, monka, die zieht
ja mal richtig heftig im vergleich zur anderen, oh die zieht krass, die zieht krass drüber
im vergleich zur anderen, alter mit der treffe ich nix, und die killt langsamer als die andere,
nee das doof, die gefällt mir nicht, die gefällt mir nicht, aber wir spielen die jetzt
trotzdem ein bisschen weiter, weil das ist die einzige waffe die es gibt, die es noch
zusätzlich gibt, die wir sinnvoll spielen können in der kombi, wo gehen wir hin, wow
gehen wir hin, wir gehen mal, ich zeige euch mal den fahrstuhl, ich zeige euch mal den
fahrstuhl in action, fahrstuhl stells, moment der vergisst immer die settings, ok ich werde
die, null, der vergisst immer die settings von der waffe, das ist pp, äh was, was war
das, alter, ok ppega, richtig ppega, alter das sackt, damit killst du nix, ok, ok, ok,
ok, damit killst du nix, mit dem anderen hättest du schon 5 gegner gebashed, damit
machst du gar nix, äh, und jetzt ist er auch noch leer, nee, nee das ist müll, smg sehr
gute idee, smg, smg spielen wir jetzt, smg legit, das ist eine gute idee, da hab ich
gar nicht dran gedacht, dass es smg gibt, smg ist hier, chris, chris spielen wir jetzt,
chris, chris ist am start, was gibts denn da, rednaut, äh mit dings, oh silencer, oh hier
ist ganz schön viel los, oh shit, pass mal auf, ich mach jetzt den, alter die zieht,
oh die zieht rüber, das ist definitiv nix für range, das ist 20 schuss, oh ich brauch
ein anderes smg, 41, 41 ist gut, 41 ist gut, haha, ok doch nicht so, doch nicht so op hipfire
wie ich gedacht hab, ist das eine vorab version, ja, die killt aber schön schnell, laser, laser,
ja, und, und ähm, links am start, silencer, das find ich poc, und die spa, oh, oh, oh,
nein, das war ne dumme idee, ok, pass mal auf, wir stellzen jetzt, stellz action, nein,
nein, nein, alter, battlefield dude, battlefield dude, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
können wir weg machen ich glaube silencer bringt jetzt erst mal hier nicht so wenn man hier so
die die stellts action macht wir machen jetzt ist auch ein silencer ah ne das ist das normale
nein excellent outplayed pass mal auf pass mal auf
3 hat pockhase pockhase 5 hat ein messer 5 hat
messer 5 hat alter oder ist leer ist leer seck seck seck seck ok ohohoho nein
monka ok hier kommt nix hin erstmal
ok ok ich habe geschossen jetzt wissen dass ich da bin
no no pleute damit trifft es nix und ihr macht über range überhaupt kein damage ok das ist
nicht gut ich muss da unten rein silencer silencer drauf nein fuck ich habe gedacht
wir können es mit silencer noch ein bisschen durchstellen glaubst du das gamer langzeit
motivation wenn es so bleibt wie jetzt nein du hast ja absolut kein anreiz irgendwas anderes
zu spielen als das minus die smg die smg ist bewegung aber ich spiele jetzt trotzdem ein
bisschen jetzt hat es viel zu wenig schuss weil ich damit ein zwanzig schuss was mal auf
die städte kommt jetzt hier lang klein macht er nicht gedacht er kommt hier jetzt lang
oder doch oder was denn jetzt so auf pepega check pepega check pepega check pepega check
sagts euch guck mal pepega check nein nein nein lass mich in your face man in your face
lass mich in ruhe komischer hund geht weg soldaten nehmen immer nur drei max mit für
weg der alles andere ist plaud plaudet nehmen jetzt mal das andere das oh nee dass die sackerwaffe
die will ich nicht achtung 3 nade pockers pfeiffett nade ich habe gehütet ich habe gehütet
mit der kannst du aber nicht schießen das geht nicht vergiss es vergiss es mit der
kannst du nicht schießen das ist umfassend das ist unmöglich über range mit der zu
hitten über range ist unmöglich über range ist nicht ich habe nur ein zwanzig schuss
sobald ich für ein ist vorbei ich weiß nicht wo die hin sind die sind bestimmt hoch die
sind bestimmt hoch hinter mir der kommt hinter mir hier ist nix mehr nix mehr da ich geh du
gehst richtig davon aus ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es gedacht ist dass du beim
magazinwechsel alles wiederbekommst das wäre wirklich nicht nur nicht nur leicht ppega
und man sollte nie hart ppega machen hart ppega ist ungesund das ist soll bestimmt nicht
so sein aber leute ohne scheiß über range ne über range ist mit dem ding nix das kannst
du komplett vergessen über range damit was du hin wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo
achtung dachstellt dachstellt guckt euch die range an pass auf guckt euch die range an
man habt ihr es gemacht habt ihr euch die range angeguckt das nerven die also wenn die
das nicht nerven dann zweifel ich komplett am dais also nicht nur so ein bisschen komplett
komplett das müssen die nerven es geht gar nicht anders
aber ein leute ich sag euch mal ein vorteil von bots
man kann sich sagen das sind bestimmt bots da oben die schießen nicht auf mich und und
dann ist man mutiger da vor zu pushen weil wenn es echte gegner werden dann würden die
mich destroyen bis ich damit meine smg ran gestellt bin ich fürchte halt es sind echte
gegner aber einfach einfach sagen das sind bots dann traut man sich eher richtige richtige
bots über range das ding so schlecht alter oh nee ok das war jetzt doch ne nummer zu
viel
das ding aber nahkampf technisch guck mal mit den ein zwei schuss nahkampf technisch
kannst du wirklich nix sagen ich kann leider nicht capturen ich könnte ein bisschen gameplay
davon gebraucht für youtube nutzt mal die pistol über range die ist nicht so der wahnsinn
also die pistols gefallen mir nicht wobei mir die die die die default die g18 oder irgendeine
g18 ist das nee was ist das ist eine g18 g57 ist das noch besser gefällt als die marktnummer
für die marktnummer habe ich habe ich zu ppega aim ich dachte da stellst einer ran machte
aber nicht ja das mit ich mein guter plan guter plan schlecht umgesetzt müsste zugeben
guter plan die ausführung war nicht gut ja es ist viel zu op die rakete startet
ist hier vielleicht noch was was ich beschen kann ist gegner blies
ey über range pass mal auf pass mal auf wir netten wie granaten den jetzt ich habe keine
granaten singel schuss wie stellt man um aber das jetzt bürst oder ok vielleicht vielleicht
geht es über range damit gescheit seh ich nix da hast du schon ein tornado ja habe ich
sogar bei mir auf youtube video gezeigt einzigen tornado den ich in der open also in dieser
betas hatte in der preview hatte ich laufen schlechtes wetter und sturm also in tornado
hatte ich in der preview auch nur einmal aber in jeder runde schlechtes wetter und einmal
tornado ich renne jetzt hier einfach mal rum weil ich guck mal der zipplein dude
was willst du machen ich habe die beste long range war für mir dafür ausgesucht aller
zeiten o o pepega gegner pepega oder um ist noch einer achtung achtung pass auf den outplay
ich jetzt fack ich dachte ich dachte also big big big brain time was ich mir gedacht
habe ist der jump drunter und während der runter jump ich hoch und dann kann ich von
oben runter best aber es hat nicht funktioniert ok wir sollten vielleicht irgendwo hin wo
das mit der smg ganz sinnvoll ist das sagt hier unten zum beispiel hier hier ist gut
hier ist nice mit der smg hier ist poggers hier ist poggers smg poggers smg was was für
meine waffe los fack ist leer warum ist sie leer nope die ist auf burst ich habe es auch
eben erst gecheckt die soll nicht leer sein ok das ist mit der smg ist tatsächlich ganz
witzig das ist mal ein bisschen was anderes einfach mal ein bisschen was anderes kommen
wir gehen jetzt hier rein der typ ist eh oben passt mal auf der typ ist eh oben braucht
man grappling hook und ich brauche ordentlich muni grappling hook mit der smg da oben ist
aber keine gute idee jawoll der wollte mich bashen der ist noch hier der ist noch hier
ich sag dir leute ist noch hier ok undurchdacht da ist undurchdacht richtig undurchdacht
hier kann man kommt man nicht durch das hätte alles müsste eigentlich gehen ich kann nicht
mehr springen leute mein jumpen ist kaputt jetzt gehts wieder so gucken wir mal ob wir
jetzt ein auto droppen können und jetzt beginnt der spannende teil wir laufen drei stunden
zum nächsten punkt mit einer smg wo wir über range nicht mal hitten können ok huge high
octane gameplay laufen porc laufen auch was hinter mir achtung flank achtung nein man
ich wollte den mega feifeld play machen mit silencer und so achtung porc wo ist er nein
lass mich in ruhe das ist der dumme hund das ist der dumme hund ey der hund soll sich verpissen
ja alles weg spray and pray ja wo ist er wo ist er wo ist der gegner man what the fuck
ok ich check nicht pp got time glaube den kann es sein dass man den mit smg moni nicht
killen kann er hat überhaupt kein damage gefressen alles kann man mit dem grappling hook wohl
auch nicht machen ich glaube die map ist aber das ist cool jetzt oder das ist wirklich nice
ok komm noch ein paar kills mit smg da wird gesprüht und gebetet wieder
da unten ist einer war das viel zu wenig schuss nächste warum immer der da stehen geblieben ist kein schimmer naja neue
map wäre ein bisschen was richtig poc wäre wenn die morgen eine neue map bringen zur open beta
aber glaube ich nicht war ein bot ja bots riecht stumm ich check messe fangen geblieben bots
mal ein bisschen chat easy chat
das funktioniert nicht richtig das funktioniert nicht richtig ich habe es ja vorhin auch ausprobiert
an den heli zu springen da geht dann einfach aus auf die rakete kann man auch nicht also nur
wenn du exakt den richtigen pixel erwischt was auch blöd ist ja nee es ist es ist dumm wie
gesagt mich hat ein bot hat mich mal mit einer brandgranate oder sowas in der richtung oder
mit einer mit der impact nade irgendwas hat schottet around the corner so war ich richtig instant one shot
so ach ihr seht ja mein desktop jetzt gar nicht
es wäre geil wenn morgen eine neue map kommt aber gehe ich nicht von aus
wirst du nur world spielen nein mache ich nicht kein new world kein new world für mich wie
findest du das ui wenn ich ehrlich bin ist kacke aus gefällt mir nicht dass das ui sieht aus als
hätte einer hat im lcss auferlehr gemacht ist es wahrscheinlich auch im endeffekt könnte ich wetten
und und und dann nicht gewusst woran was hin packen soll gefällt mir nicht so als haben wir
wieder hier die fetten aber ich muss mal den soundtrack aus man die fetten ganz am start ok wir
stellst mal ein bisschen flugzeug das haben wir heute noch gar nicht gemacht weil ich sehe
natürlich keine gegner aber ich drehe einfach mal drauf hier irgendwas ich sehe hier nix da ist
was da guckt man wie seht ihr wie klein die sind das ist kein wunder dass ich die netz
seh die sind ja einfach nur zwei pixel groß ich muss euch sagen ich finde das scale von
dem battlefield zu groß also ich ich mochte es an battlefield immer dass du gegner nicht
mit der lupe suchen musstest und nicht wie in warzone teilweise zwei pixel um die ecke gucken
wir haben den pro heli am start guckt euch das mal an der heli pro ist am start der kann
man lohnt sich das game kann man noch nicht sagen und ich sehe ich sehe nix man kann nicht
spotten ich sehe die map nicht ich sehe selbst keine gegner was willst was willst du tun würde
der echte gangster jetzt sagen
ich habe es komplett klar gesehen den gegner ich also ich habe so klar habe ich noch nie den
gegner gesehen als den komplett komplett klar alles alles bis auf die fingernägel habe ich
gesehen von dem der ist viel zu hoch der fliegt finde ich ganz brauchbar der stirbt zumindest
nicht aber man sieht halt nichts ich hätte irgendwas
was hinter ich da irgendwas was nicht kaputt geht auf jeden fall visibilities für den arsch
ja sehe ich genauso ich kann einfach nur auf gut glück wisst ihr jetzt verstehe ich das
ich habe doch am anfang gesagt ground combat also das infanterie gameplay fühlt sich komplett
die also entkoppelt vom vehikel und er gameplay an ja kein wunder kein wunder die sehen alle
nix die sehen einfach alle nix denen geht es wie mir kein wunder dass du aus der luft
nie gebashed wirst außer von dem heli der zwei zentimeter über dir fliegt aber du ihn
nicht hörst die sehen einfach alle nix und beide warum stirbt das ding nicht
es wäre pocke wenn ich spotten könnte spotten wäre massive pock ist denn die garage eingepackt
gerade ne spotten ist broken ich weiß ob spotten mal wieder geht irgendwann okay zum glück
ist es vorbei zum glück ist es vorbei so und verlieren wir die runde nope wir dominierten
pock so muss es sein was ist hier los was kann sagen was geht mit dem so das wäschen
wir jetzt jetzt mit smg smg legit spreien prä silencer was das war das ein laser war
das ein laser eben okay wir schießen uns jetzt aufs dach und
es war schwierig leute zu finden ich habe youtube geguckt okay der könnte kriegen der
könnte kriegen habe ich auf die habe ich auf die profil keine twitter account verlinkt
so und dann habe ich es irgendwann anders gemacht gebe zu ich habe ein wenig gegen
meine eigenen regel verstoßen ich habe einfach 30 accounts 30 profil aufgemacht und abgeguckt
und dann muss ich gucken wer mir gefolgt ist ich mache so unüberlegt war ich keine giveaways
mehr es war dumm für die leute weil sie wenig schlechtere chancen haben es war dumm für
mich weil ich kaum leute gefunden habe den ich was geben kann also über das wie ich
es gesagt habe da ich es mal richtig hängen geblieben muss ich nächstes mal anders machen
aber es ist egal morgen morgen könnt ihr alles spielen so ich brauche eine map ob der
mich sieht wo muss ich denn hin wo haben wir die gegner was da ober das ist wie das ist
uncaptured seriously die rakete ist uncaptured da müssen wir hin da müssen wir hin vielleicht
war es der twitter account auch nicht wert was meinst du ach mir zu folgen das ist es
auch nicht wert ich würde mir auch nicht folgen ich würde mir auch noch für giveaways folgen
easy wisst ihr wie ich das machen würde ich würde dem typ folgen wo ich den key haben
will und dann würde ich einfach wenn es vorbei ist direkt wieder anfollowen sag euch wie
es ist realer talk heute ach sich einen machen das würde ich auch nicht machen oh jawoll
über 50 kilometer mit der smg ok pass mal auf progas progas richtig progas da unten
war einer habt ihr ihn gesehen schreckt mann in your face so mag ich das in the tingos
im ist schon zu geben ab und zu gibt es mal ganz coole place da ist wieder nix da das
mein ich klasse da was ist happening was was zum was what the fuck natürliche heli bewegung
ja wir sollten sowas auf so irgendwelche verschwörungstheorie seien machen wir irgendwas mit ufos ich glaube
das kriegt man später echt gut rein wie die range ach so moment mein spotting war oben
auf dem dach nicht hier keck wo ist denn hier was da da jawoll running simulator man konnte
früher ja auch die gegner anpegnen also die die teamets teamets anpingen so komm mal her
hallo bot oh panzer huge nade versus panzer alles klar es gibt kein kontextmenü du kannst
auch nicht einfach kurdi die die dinger anpingen wie battlefield 3 wo du einfach auf den panzer
gezielt hast dann gesagt hast halt pick me up oder sowas der enemy tank war ziemlich
ppega na intense gameplay huge hier oben hatte ich den sturm hier oben hatte ich den sturm
daxa ein assi KL nur bots sind ought only egal wo du hingehst wir taxane es izì und
und das ist nix da ich renne seit 20 min über die map oder ist was okay
nur AI. Oh Leute, ich lief jetzt gleich. Ich lief gleich, ich hab kein Bock gegen AI zu spielen.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli. Nee, es ist schlimmer, Leute. Es ist schlimmer. Die Bots fliegen den Heli.
Wenn es ja wenigstens die Noobs wären. Die Bots fliegen den Heli.
Wer dachte, die Krönung ist die Noobs fliegen den Heli. Ist vorbei. Bots fliegen den Heli.
Ich würde ihn ja gerne spotten. Ich würde ihn echt gerne spotten. Ist das möglich, ihn zu spotten?
Nein. Denied.
Das Ding über Range. Seht ihr das Symbol in der Mitte? Man sieht sogar.
Schreckt. Man sieht sogar, wenn man schießen kann. Hab ich gerade gemerkt. Guckt mal. Jetzt kann man nicht schießen. Jetzt kann man schießen. Jetzt nicht. Jetzt kann man schießen.
Jetzt kann man schießen. Man erkennt es sogar. Bashing, alle bashing. Wo ist er? Wo ist er? Oh, wir ratzen.
Auf. Bam. Okay, meine gute Tat für den Abend ist erfüllt. Es reicht jetzt. Ab jetzt wird nur noch Nahkampf gebashed. Aber ehrlich gesagt, Leute, also die SMG ist jetzt für die Map nicht das Beste.
Huge Rakete. Ich bin im Prinzip nur am rumrennen und einen Gegner killen und dann gehe ich wieder und dann ist wieder weg. Guckt jetzt. Jetzt können wir da ran.
Pepega. Und jetzt spawnen sie hinter uns. Ich wette mit euch, die spawnen jetzt hinter uns, weil die können jetzt rein spawnen. Da ist schon der erste.
Hallo? Nee, SMG, Suck. Wenn es ja richtige Nice Fights, GG Eats Nice Fights, irgendwie Close Quarters gehen würde, aber so ist das nix.
Wir testen nochmal. Was gibt es denn sonst noch? Wir probieren erstmal ein paar Waffen durch. Wir haben ja mehr oder weniger alles gemacht, außer Chat geflogen.
Jetzt haben wir sonst noch. PBX 45. Soll das eine UMP sein? Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Mischung aus einer UMP und dieser einen Waffe aus Black Ops 1.
Und ich weiß, wie die heißt. Die sagt LMG Hammer, LMG Legit. Marksman Sniper. Sniper ist wahrscheinlich Bolt Action und Marksman ist wahrscheinlich Tap Tap Tap. Probieren wir mal.
Was sind das eigentlich für hässliche, für hässliche Comrade? Hier Scopes. Pass mal auf, jetzt mit meinem Pepega Aim.
Oh je, oh je, oh je. Hallo? Aufpicken, please. Der heilt auch so. Der pickt es nicht immer. Der müsste es aber picken, aber er pickt es nicht immer.
Ob die DRMs was taugen, das sehen wir jetzt. Wir können auch das Ding nehmen. Ah, das kann man, das ist ein ACOG. Ok.
Ok, ok. Hier, das habe ich noch nicht raus, wie das funktioniert. Stell es jetzt rauf. Ok. Muss ich vielleicht anders machen.
Der hat mich mit dem Assault Rifle gebesselt, Assault Rifle Beste. Und du musst mit dem Ding langsam schießen. Wobei, musst du mit dem Ding langsam schießen? Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
Ja, anders triffst du nicht. Anders triffst du nicht.
Ja, wenn ich wüsste, wie man vorhalten muss, dann wäre das sehr Pock, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Sagen Sie mal, stelltsen die sich von hinten gerade ran an uns? Könnte doch sein, dass hier was stellst. Nö. Ist doch K. B.o.M. noch. Ich habe von K. B.o.M. eine Weile nichts mehr gehört.
Ich denke mal dass der gerade nicht so sehr am spiel ist
Ok hier geht nichts. Das da drüben ist gecaptured. Es ist so dumm. Es ist clusterfuck oder rennen gerade
so macht es keinen spaß ok ich habe legit keine ahnung wie man wie man vorhalten muss mit dem
ding weil wahrscheinlich bin ich viel zu weit und orientiere mich an der komischen waffe also an
der patrone die tracer oh hier ist was guck guckst du guckst du
was hä moment wollte mir das game kann sagen ich habe den gekillt wie habe ich den
unmöglich den letzten never habe ich den letzten gekillt also entweder war das assist also entweder
wäre ist das dies irgendwie als fach gewesen das spiel ist so groß gebe ich luiz gebe ich dir
komplett recht mir wäre eine fokussiertere map und sei es auch nur 64 spieler ich habe auch keine
problem 32 spieler die map ist einfach zu groß und zu viele spieler ist entweder clusterfuck oder
nichts los ja es ist ich weiß dass du das an dem handsymbol siehst aber es hat eben diesen
bling bling sauer festschott gegeben was sich wirklich sinn ergeben hat eben die hier ein
gehen wir dann jetzt hin hier da da bastion alter bastion bastion guck mal hier
achtung die kommen jetzt von der vorne wenn gebäscht von mir da sind sie guck hier ich
kann es halt nicht spotten achtung achtung so ein nicer stells und dann ist einfach das
spielverderber am start und der corona wir haben schon 21 20 die zeit ging schnell rum
ok das war marksman und jetzt jetzt werden mich alle hassen shotgun shotgun passt mal auf shotgun
ist das auto die pump action also auf shotgun range ran war schon mal gar nicht so einfach
ist auf der map guck mal beim bär wow ok easy easy easy das war kein one tap leute das war kein
one tap das war direkt in your face aus zwei meter hat das lag ich guck mal ich guck mal
ich guck mal was das für ammo hat gleich wir testen jetzt wir testen jetzt einfach noch
ein paar dinge weil was soll man sonst großartig machen was soll man sonst großartig machen kann
ich spawn kann man bei der shotgun ammo wechseln probiere ich jetzt gleich aus probiere ich
gleich aus muss ich mal gucken wo ich jetzt hier am besten rein spore das ist jetzt alles
kein close quarter zeug hier ja bei dem in combat also was kann man machen allerdings
backshot slugshell was lag das ding was über die halbe map gekillt hat
schauen wir mal ok man muss wirklich genau halten der tut ist doch jeder vor oder
aber da vorne kommt jetzt was achtung achtung achtung hat er mich zu 16 ausgab hat er mich
zu 16 ausgab oder irgendwas in der richtung ich bin mir nicht sicher wie die waffe kratz
also wie das funktioniert hier mit slug ammo ob das ist das eine kugel das ist eine kugel
tatsächlich ok ok ok das geht wirklich über größere range aber wenn es nicht wenn es
im nahe kampf nicht one shot ist es auch nicht viable ok keine ahnung wie man da vorhalten
ist ok das ist der sack extrem so was spiele ich nicht das ist ja mal richtig dumm das
war heute die leute nicht ne das ist dumm aber das ist wirklich unsinnig wozu da kann
ich ja guck mal mit jedem assault rifle bist du da besser bedient so 360 noscope achtung
jetzt kommt xx hd sniper gott am start was haben wir hier die ironside sniper bam xx hd
ironside sniper gott am start ist das überhaupt eine bolt action hinten hinten hinten was
das ist kein one shot das ist schuld schuld es war kein headshot aber das war ok glaubt
ich glaube die also ich mein ich finde es geil wenn sniper sappen ich hasse wenn die
sniper zu stark sind im game das kann das kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden wenn die
sniper zu stark sind da spielt jeder sniper und nervt ok das ist nix hallo hallo wo ist
mein mini pack hin mein mini pack ist einfach weg so viel damage wie slug ammo ja da ist
aber ich habe da auch die maus zu schnell für eingestellt für jetzt super krasse sniper
action deswegen spiele ich auch ungern aus anbett company 2 sniper ich mag das in battlefield
deswegen ist es ja teilweise scheibenwächer ich mag das wenn du dich relativ easy so ungefähr
mit einem dreiviertel mousepad einmal drehen kannst dann hast du keine probleme ansonsten
würde ich das auch ein bisschen langsamer spielen aber ich mag das nicht gerade battlefield
wo du permanent weil sie gucken muss was so um nicht drumherum passiert xx hd sniper gott
ist unterwegs
ist ja gar nichts mehr ja wohl dann die scope senzi runter stellen das ist in der tat eine
exzellente idee bin ich noch gar nicht drauf gekommen kann man die nur für sniper runter
stellen das wäre natürlich mal extrem pock dann könnte ich da können können ich tatsächlich
sogar was treffen wo sind wir hier horny xx hd sniper gott am start acht und weiter geht's
auf reddit redet wieder jeder komplett durch über jeden pf release inwiefern gut oder
schlecht wird gut oder schlecht durchgedreht xx hd ist am start hier xx hd achtung scope
scope drauf jetzt beim ach du scheiße wie enden mit dem ding es war collateral ich blick
nehmen wir durch zu viel ich bin ich bin xx sniper gott hd ist eingelost geht nicht mehr
vergesst alles klar x hat sich aus xx hd warum habe ich einfach 22 in dieser runde ich habe
nichts gemacht einfach gar nix hat jemand im chat ahnung von home assistant esp home ja
bisschen bisschen ich habe das schon ich habe das schon mal verwendet habe mich dann aber
dagegen entschieden weil ich die meisten sachen eher customized programmiert gebraucht habe
und ich gerne selbst programmieren ok das sagt was das für ein visier das ist der richtige
xx hd scope eye scope eye scope hd jetzt haben was achtung eye scope hd eye scope hd man jawoll
eye scope hd jetzt gehts los hier poc champ achtung achtung jetzt mal mal jetzt jetzt
switchen wir auf ironside und bashen die ok das war dumm richtig alter das ist die sens
zu hoch mit ironside einfach zu hoch treffnix no scope über uns oder unter uns doch der
läuft weiter achtung scheiße hör mal auf es ist zu hoch für steiner action alle sind
so richtig treffnix oh nein die rakete oh das ding geht aber ab sind die alle verreckt
jetzt die da dran waren massive sniper action eye snipes man ok ich bin down durch was auch
immer space x fehlstart aber mit dem anderen scope gehts tatsächlich besser dann hast
du nämlich die scope sense am start die nicht so krass also das nicht so nicht so hoch ist
ich komm spielen jetzt was lmg legit lmg haben wir noch gar nicht gespielt achtung achtung
achtung stells stells time stells time 32 wo wir sind einfach nur sinnlos im kreis rum
gerannt und haben dummes zeug gemacht wahrscheinlich die hälfte wieder bots jetzt wird endlich
mal gesprayt genau eine sache die ich die mir wirklich schwer fällt in dem spiel ist
in battlefield 3 also ich denke jetzt mal in battlefield 3 zurück da hast du da ist
ein gegner nicht so extrem instant von still zu movement gesprungen das hier kommt mir
fast ein bisschen wie in overwatch vor overwatch ad ad ad spam wartet mal mal zum vergleich
muss ich euch mal zeigen was ich mein by the way ich sollte vielleicht mal das so machen
dass man was sieht zeigen wir mal kurz was ich meine an was mich das ein bisschen erinnert
falls man das sieht overwatch ad ad spam wie sich die gegner hier bewegen ja ja in overwatch
war das auch total mega mega plötzlich wie gegner sich bewegt haben und so kommt mir das
ein bisschen was jetzt hier sieht das meine ich weil und der spam noch nicht mal richtig
er läuft ad ad normalerweise hast du den overwatch gemacht und das ist so unpredictable teilweise
aber ich will was auch sein kann ist leute wisst ihr was es wahrscheinlich sein wird
wahrscheinlich einfach alt wahrscheinlich einfach old af hat fps ja so gibt es noch
was lmg legit wollte mal ausprobieren lmg legit und mit great immer hier rein hier rein
der typ ist einfach abgestürzt monka so was kann man da drauf machen dort was ist das
hier anti anti stels leitmaschine zu press rounds einfach so hier gesprayt mit lmg da
kommt was gesegelt ist doch gar nichts oder ist hier was da jawoll ganz schön schnell
mit lmg da tut ganz ehrlich die beta maps sieht aus als wird sie kein spaß meine ja
gebe ich dir recht die beta maps sieht wirklich nicht sondern ich inspiriert oder oder innovativ
oder so also die staunmomente sind bei das halo tunnel wieder die staunmomente sind bei
mir auch ausgeblieben und wisst ihr was mich ja ein bisschen wie soll ich sagen ein bisschen
ja zurückhaltend stimmt über das game ist als die uns die map angekündigt haben als
sie uns die map angekündigt haben haben die gesagt das ist die beste map also jetzt ohne
witz die haben gesagt die beste map also die haben nein das stimmt nicht sie haben nicht
gesagt die beste map sie haben gesagt das ist die map wo alle immer am meisten spaß
haben und also was ja im prinzip so heißt wie es ist die beste map monka monka check
hier nichts mehr wo ist hier was wo ist hier was ok ich ok das daun ohne das gegner ach
du scheiße monka lmg legit alda shanghai fand ich in battlefield auf hier schrecklich sagt
der chat ja ich fand shanghai auch nicht geil ich fand in battlefield 4 sauvott fand ich cool
ich habe jetzt bin ich bin ja nicht so der große ich war battlefield 3 bin ich bin riesen
battlefield 3 fern aber battlefield 4 jetzt nicht ganz so stark also sauvott fand ich nice die
radarschlüssel map ging mir mega offen auf dem keks was hier warum nimmst du ein seht ihr mal
wie unfair der spawn ist gleich weiß nicht wo er ist nach oben ist er
mann du bist ja laufen immer von der seite gebäscht immer von der seite weg ich will
das mal ein bisschen lmg spielen aber nein geht jetzt nicht heinal resort war ok der
heinal resort ist dass das mit dem hotel was einbrechen kann
war also mit lmg mit lmg legit zu treffen ist nicht ohne das staubt ja wie sonst was
ein seriously lmg sagt du gewinnt kein ganz fein lmg legit so wir switchen jetzt noch mal
jetzt wird jetzt echt mal wieder auf was was gescheit hier so excellent ich sage man kann
die besten waffen mit webster spielen macht die beste mobility man hat einfach das beste von
allem außer 100 prozent res aber das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm 100 prozent res kann man hier
rüber ich werde nicht wahr mit dem macht ihr nichts draus ich auch nicht wirklich ich spiele
sein weil es die einzige map ist aber moment moment point 6 6 wie für uns das
oh das ist dumm die basten uns oder ich verstehe kann ich auch sein stehen die oben drauf unter
einfach mal runter hauen mal gucken was passiert in your face man ist okay damit
habe ich nicht gerechnet aber jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich selbst auf die hand
geschlagen das war sehr clever max 8 8 8 17 17
ich sage ich sage euch leute es soll frei fliegt einfach es soll frei für spiel
die basht das soll frei für gleich besch jetzt natürlich die frage wo die hin sind da
oben passbar und nein ich hätte ihn so krass gebashed von der seite der ist hier hochgegangen
ich hätte ihn so krass gebashed von der seite ich werde ich werde direkt vor dem hochgestellten
hätten gebashed hallo ich will mir mein klappling hoch wo ist denn hallo please
ich sage euch es soll frei fliegt einfach easy easy der kompass von unten oder oder nicht
hallo alles war ein bot ok das war ein bot kein wunder das er so komische dinger gemacht hat
das ist ei ja das ist aber kein ei ei ja ei leute jetzt für all dies wo ich die
voll mein bot trend nicht mitgekriegt haben ich finde es ist das schlimmste an dem game
also ich sage ich sage euch jetzt mal ehrlich wie es ist also wenn das game rauskommt und das
ding hat bei really spots in diesem ausmaß wie jetzt dann spiele ich das nicht ganz ehrlich
das macht mir doch so viel spaß mann ich habe es macht mir es versaut mir komplett den spaß
gegen bots zu spielen komplett ich hasse es gegen bots zu spielen vor allem wenn es halt kein ich
spiele gegen bots aber ist sondern ein ganz normaler ganz normal multiplayer server den anschein
erweckt du spielst gegen spieler und dann dann siehst du bei einem kill auf fack du hättest
dich gar nicht anstrengen müssen das war ja nur ein kack bot das erinnert mich auch an mobile
games ja ehrlich legit real talk ja so ist es bot ist sack nein nein lass mich in ruhe weiß
ich was mich beschießt aber irgendwas warum geht er wo ist eigentlich mal medipack
die könnten den medipack zumindest schnelleren medipack recharge geben als das nicht so ist
ja das mit dem das mit dem operator auf dem ganzen schlagplatt vier bis fünf soldaten
rumlaufen lassen das ist ja bei jedem battlefield so die nehmen den sturm soldaten aus battlefield
3 das sieht auch überall gleich aus ein problem den du tatsächlich hast mit dem operator ist
dass freund und feind komplett gleich aussehen zumindest sehe ich da keinen unterschied was
aber auch sein kann dass du es generell nicht erkennst weil weil alles hier nicht zu erkennen
ist so richtig hoffentlich gibt es bots die haben bots so krass beworben das wird drin sein
hat er mich getriggert oder was das war die normale piste man
hier ist gut hier ist guter spawn guter spawn guter spawn exzellent spawn
ok nicht so exzellent oh nicht so exzellent spawn oh er hat es wieder nicht aufge- der hat
mann der hat den medipack wieder nicht aufgenommen panzer lasst mich in ruhe panzer lasst mich in ruhe
die normale pistole kannst du auf ein dreierbast umstellen das habe ich ausprobiert das ist auch
nervig wenn wenn wenn du sachen machst die eigentlich gut wird also hast eine gute entscheidung
getroffen der situation aber das spiel sagt nein hallo
jebaited jebaited wo ist hier was ja du kannst mich ruhig fahren das ist gut
die dudes mann das sind keine bots das sind echte spieler lull was ist denn mit denen
kaputt ich bleibe jetzt hier einfach stehen warum soll ich mich bewegen ich bleibe einfach
stehen die rennen jetzt wieder rein ich weiß nicht was es war aber bestimmt irgendwas
was das mich basht oh ich muss weg ich muss weg ok hast du wirklich nur so um die 70 fps
ich habe keine ahnung was die fps anzeige da oben bedeutet aber ja wahrscheinlich also
da hätte ich eben da wäre ich auch hier müssen wir hin da wäre ich eben davon ausgegangen
das waren bots aber das waren keine bots ja komm on hab den gesehen hab den gesehen
oh die spawn jetzt da oben
denke er gpu ist fps ja aber was was ist denn fps durch millisekunden fps durch millisekunden
wäre ja das was du siehst durch 1000 dass es auf frames pro sekunde kommt also mal mal
1000 ach kein schimmer ich weiß es nicht checkt eh keiner es wäre cool wenn es einfach
eine ganz normale fps anzeige ich könnte einen anmachen aber mein nvidia overlay geht
nicht auch immer da einfach ein panzer mein nvidia overlay geht nicht es ist abgekackt
seit dem letzten du siehst einfach nichts in diesem spiel siehst einfach nichts siehst
nichts siehst nichts siehst nichts aber anscheinend bist du jetzt tot ah steam das ist eine gute
idee hat origin nicht auch sowas was ist über origin hat origin auch sowas echt origin hat
das wie wo was wie geht das chat ihr müsst mir das jetzt müssen wir das zeigen wie es
geht alt f1 geht nicht tut sich nichts fraps genau fraps fraps richtig gute idea fraps
einfach fraps installiert ich muss ich muss langsamer schießen ich treffe ja gar nichts
fraps shift f1 shift f1 und jetzt einstellung
ich weiß nicht
ach komm das oben muss reichen bin ja nicht mehr allzu lange und reicht schon
informatiker beide was hat das mit informatik zu tun
wo war der tunnel hier drüben war der tunnel tunnel stellt ins loch
wenn ich mit dem friseur gespielt hätte garantiert irgendeinen dummen spruch gemacht ich weiß
es einfach
die stehen eh da oben und aimen ab die die aimen ab und werfen nades rein
pass mal auf wir machen ich mache jetzt big brain move jawoll jawoll jawoll jawoll
nein alter heli heli stellt lasst mich nur schrägt
pass durch die deck durch die decke was denn das für ein scheiß mann ich hab so mich
so mich huge poggers sixhead mäßig angestellt aber nein der heli schießt mich durch die
decke ab
übrigens weiteres problem mit so vielen spieler und dieser clusterfuck mechanik du kannst
alleine keinen punkt klieren insoweit dass du ihn einnehmen kannst selbst mit dem squad
stelle ich mir schwierig vor
ok der hat nicht mit mir gerechnet
hallo ich will aufs dach doch
dach war hört ihr die helis auch nicht
du hörst die helis nicht du hörst immer nur die schüsse einschlagen die helis sind
nicht hörbar man merkt dass die battlefield mechanik gut für ja die map ist auch zu groß
die map ist zu groß und der map flow und der aufbau ist nicht so nice
aber das nichtsdestotrotz das macht schon richtig bock deswegen fände ich es halt dumm
wenn es an solchen sachen letztendlich scheitert die sie ja eigentlich besser können
nein nein heli heli piss dich
ich dachte können hüfte sprengen also eigentlich eigentlich können dies ja besser
wobei wenn man ehrlich ist wer was meint ihr wie viele leute noch jetzt ernst gemeinte
frage ich weiß wirklich was meint ihr wie viele leute die battlefield 3 und 4 gemacht
haben sind überhaupt noch da
was gibt es sonst noch für spezialisten ist egal
du brauchst keinen anderen das ist der einzige spezialist der sinnvoll ist zu spielen weil
er einfach op ist fack ist und alles kann am besten
habe ich hier vielleicht reinigen
also ja es gibt noch andere es gibt medik es gibt medik der poggers retzen kann
ja ist ja gut du hast medik der eine pistole der kann leute mit der pistole so wie anna
in overwatch kann heilen da kann leute 100 prozent retzen du hast ein typ mit einem robot
der hund und und sentry gun und du hast ein sniper dude mit drohnen und keine ahnung also
klassisches zeug
aber das ist der einzige den du spielen musst weil webster op ist einfach mega op du hast
die beste mobility mit diesem hook
du hast die
du hast die besten waffen
ich weiß nicht so genau von wo ich beschossen wurde ehrlich gesagt
ich bin mir nicht so sicher von wo ich beschossen werde
aber von da nein du sollst mich nicht kind und die scale das scale der map ist einfach
zu groß
ja die waffen kann jeder haben deswegen brauchst du ja auch kein specialist mehr zu picken
oder keine klasse die vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen weaker ist in manchen situationen
und dafür die für dich beste waffe hat ja ja die waffen sind unabhängig aber deswegen
kannst du halt mit dem besten operator die beste waffe ausrüsten was den operator noch
mehr op macht
also ich habe schon aufgehört zu schießen weil ich gedacht habe dagegen fünf kugeln
den kopf das reicht
ja ja die weg mich nur alles klar
so du kannst du kannst den besten operator nehmen mit der besten mobility mit den besten
waffen dadurch dass sie eben alle ausrüsten ganz richtig und du kannst quads leute wieder
beleben auch kein ding weil es ja auch jeder kann
die möchte gerade nicht sterben
das hier ist ein mittelgroßer map ja es kommt ja noch dabei
das ist nur eine mittelgroße map korrekt
ja jetzt bin ich
guck mal sowas das ist einfach op du kannst einfach so krass moveen und und flanken du
flankst solo 128 spieler
aber es war doof guck mal der hätte sich hier hoch hocken können jetzt
wenn du mit dem haken ein heli triffst kann ich dir sagen was dann passiert dann ziehst
du dich bis zum heli hoch bis die dauer das ist dauer begrenzt und dann fällst du einfach
runter passiert nichts haben wir ganz am anfang ausprobiert
wie die hinten teilweise jetzt könnte man eigentlich denken vielleicht rettet mich einer
aber wie sagt bloß der rettet mich oder ist das ein gegner man weiß es halt nicht ist
es ein gegner ist es kein gegner ist es freundlich ist es man weiß es nicht man hat keine ahnung
nach dem match bettke jahr nach dem match ich gucke aber noch chat ich gucke aber noch
chat durch dann ich bin ich ich bin nicht instant off oder so
morgen ist freitag letzter arbeitstag wir hatten heute lustige veranstaltung auf der
wtf also was lustige veranstaltung es war so eine motivationsrede und jetzt jetzt kommt
es hat das überlebt ernsthaft wtf es und die haben gesagt sie haben eine neue marketing
aktion geplant und jetzt haltet euch mal fest six hack six hat marketing aktionen die wollen
unser firmen logo auf den mond schicken jetzt ohne scheiß das haben die wirklich erzählt
wir haben gesagt wenn wenn mal wieder was zum mond fliegt dann dann werden sie das so
managt oder werden sie das ist das versuchen aus unserer firmen logo zum mond mit fliegt
jetzt ohne legit ich das ist so dumm also was heißt dumm eigentlich ist cool also visionstechnisch
das ist so abgedreht das könnte ich mir gar nicht ausdenken jetzt die wollen unser firmen
logo zum mond schießen also wenn ihr irgendwo mal hört frankfurter bank fliegt auf den
mond dann wisst ihr wo ich arbeite ultra schlau also wenn das klappt ist das huge pr
es ist ziemlich dumm wie ich hier rennen beide bei nummer so du triffst mich nicht nein du
triffst mich nicht lull ok trifft mich doch was das kosten muss das ist bestimmt nicht
billig ich weiß ich was kostet man genommen man nimmt eine normale rakete und möchte
es nur in die umlaufbahn pusten und sagen wir mal es ist ein kilo schwer weiß jemand
was das kostet ein kilo ins welt anschießen was kostet ein kilo zirka zehntausend euro
das sind dann schon coole battlefield moments sowas hier so ich habe legit kein blau jetzt
jetzt retz retz stellts achtung huge revive übrigens auch eine mega nervige geschichte
dass man die waffe aufhebt ok hallo kann man das ding irgendwie disablen oder so ok low
q kill streak der commander krieger baut sie eine cringe so cringe ich wusste ja damals
immer mich zusammenreißen ich mich nicht bremtschäme bei den aktionen bis hier wo
ich auch mich immer richtig richtig hallo richtig richtig fremd schämen muss ist weil
es ja kein windows windows released worden und die leute die immer noch 2021 lustig
sein wollen sagt window oder oder mikro weich oder sowas ist da zieht es bei mir auch alles
zusammen nicht weil ich microsoft fan bin das wisst ihr nicht getroffen wie der letzte
scheißen achtung 6 hat heim pass mal auf wenn das klappt klipp klipp massive klipp nein
geklaut kill geklaut ok leute wie fandet ihr den stream soll ich morgen noch mal eine runde
stream lief ja eigentlich ziemlich gut jetzt plus kills eine runde hat gesagt aber wir
müssen auch wir müssen nämlich auch ich mach mal kurz zu wir müssen nämlich auch noch
was machen demnächst ich zeig euch mal kurz auf twitter tier rating bf maps muss ich mal
kurz aufräumen schrieb ihr den trust twitter wir müssen demnächst nämlich auch china
chinesen zeug flaschen guckt ich hab wieder was ich hab wieder chinesische china chinesen
namensstaat kamera die können wir nicht flaschen gosund steckdosen die sind nicht wirklich
vom china chinesen aber über amazon und die sind vom aliexpress chinesen zehn zehn thermometer
also luftfeuchtigkeit total sinnlos dass ich zehn bestellt aber es hat irgendwie nur drei
euro das stück oder drei dollar das stück oder sowas gekostet ich hab gesagt komm scheiß
bestellt zehn stück müssen wir flaschen demnächst also wir haben großes großes größeres
programm ich glaube morgen mache ich erst noch mal ein video zu battlefield wo ich dann
mal wirklich auf die probleme die ich jetzt festgestellt habe eingehen werde zum beispiel
bots sacken ja button für visiere switchen wäre cool ich meine es nicht f zwischen diesen
zwei visieren sondern generell visiere switchen über hotkeys dieses komische crisis menü
da mag ja mag ja ganz nice sein wenn man nicht wenn man die shortcuts nicht weiß aber wenn
es muss über shortcuts gehen man wenn man auf respawn wartet sieht man nichts was abgeht
ja du siehst nichts beim respawn also du siehst nicht was bei den gegnern los ist du weißt
nicht wann respawn ist und wir ja sie soll was in desync as fuck gegner halten irgendwie
unterschiedlich viel aus ist auch ganz merkwürdig eventuell wegen der platte webster mit grappling
hook ist op as fuck man bleibt öfters mal hängen beim kreppeln ok ja das ist vielleicht
eher ausgleichen spawn ist oft unfair hinter gegnern am am sektor warum ist eh waffen nehmen
und retten gleichzeitig stimmt dass man mag wechseln schneller ist als nachladen das kann
durchaus sein das habe ich gar nicht ausprobiert du hast zumindest nahezu unendliche munition
mit mech swap naja unendlich ist jetzt übertrieben aber du brauchst also genug dass du kein support
brauchst das war was ich am webster am dem webster gameplay auch doof finde ist du musst
ja normalerweise eine gute position erarbeiten in battlefield und dann wenn du die posi hast
kannst du halt ausnutzen bist relativ safe kannst bashen wenn du gebasht wirst hast du
wieder kack posi so aber dadurch dass du mit webster easy auf gute posis kommst ist es
genauso unsicher weil du nicht weißt von welcher seite dich demnächst einer wegstellt
das ist also also easy und nervig gleichzeitig ja und revive ist halt auch doof du weißt
nicht ob die leute releasen wenn du zu ihnen rennst oder ob du gerätzt wirst weil du gar
nicht siehst ob er bei dir in der nähe ist und es dauert auch lang die zeiten sind auch
mega lang ja und du kannst halt alles was op ist auf einem char machen du nimmst webster
als specialist assault rifles du kannst retten du kannst medipacks nehmen du hast granaten
du hast alles ja und die und die fahrzeug physik ist auch komisch dass das luft luft
kampf ist komplett entkoppelt von infanterie fühlt sich so an klar du wirst ab und zu
mal vom heli gebasht aber erinnert sich noch jemand an battlefield 3 angenommen du hast
immer mal in battlefield 3 nehmen wir mal eine heli heavy map nimmst du kark island
so wenn da der heli angestellt ist dann ging es um den heli entweder hast du heli gebasht
oder heli hat dich gebasht das war halt impact es ist aus der luft auch teilweise alles so
klein hast du nicht spotten is broken map geht nicht das werden sie aber wahrscheinlich
fixen ja naja aktuell aktuell ist da ach du meinst
die brauchen noch zeit ja mal gucken mal gucken ob das ausreicht also wenn ich so komische
designentscheidungen wie bots sehe dann frage ich mich wirklich ob sie noch ganz normal
sind teilweise mein bots das ist das schlimmste ohne mist also bots ist der bisher der grund
wo ich sagen würde wenn bots bei release in dieser in dieser häufigkeit drin sind
dann spiele ich es nicht ist ohne scheiß ist egal wie gut das game ist ich sehe es
nicht ein dass ich in der runde irgendwie jeden dritten vierten kill teilweise oder
jeden zweiten kill zwischendurch das ist bots sind ich habe teilweise 5er killstreak
gehabt das war fünf bots in folge kann doch nicht sein bots in titanfall in titanfall
hattest du ja auch nicht wirklich bots da hattest du ja doch du hattest du hattest
du hattest bots du hattest halt diese komischen diese komischen frag mich nicht was das war
diese unsinnigen die eigentlich keiner wo nichts passiert ist du hattest da diese komischen
roboter rumlaufen so was sie nichts gemacht haben als bots lieber bots als spmm naja naja
das eine hat mit dem anderen ja gar nichts zu tun es ist ja nicht so als müsstest du
sagen oh ja wenn du bots raus nimmst brauchst du spmm und wenn du spmm raus machst brauchst
du bots das also das steht ja in keinem wie sagt man in keinem kausalen zusammenhang bots
oder spmm also einfach beides nicht easy einfach beides nicht rein machen manche sind schlechter
als bots haben sie halt pech für die leute könnte man ein bot only server machen habe
ich auch kein problem mit ich will nur nicht in einem normalen multiplayer server das das
treffen genau bots war eher dass du dann dass du dein kindstück auffüllen konntest ja ach
ich bin mal gespannt was da kommt also an sich von vom vom kern von der grundlage macht
das game spaß also richtig richtig richtig geil aber so ein paar dinger die könnten
es echt versauen und ich bin immer noch kein fan der map und der größe von allem bisher
war das cool in battlefield dass du eben nicht jeden pixel gucken musstest genau ob das
nicht irgendwas ist in in diesem battlefield musst du quasi jeden pixel checken ob das
nicht vielleicht ein gegner aus 5000 meter entfernung sein könnte ok leute betke time
jetzt gucken wir noch mal schnell chat irgendwas übersehen weiß ich ob das konstant an ist
keine ahnung stimmt die decke ist nicht mal kaputt gegangen als der heli reingeballert
hat da durch die fenster geschossen ja die zerstörung ist auch so ein punkt die zerstörung
wirkt irgendwie man hat sie gemacht weil es in battlefield ist in battlefield 3 war es
ja teilweise schon weniger als in bad company 2 was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht schlecht fand
weil es hat zum game gepasst battlefield 4 hat man es mit revolution stealth total übertrieben
diesmal ist es so es ist halt da weil es ein battlefield game ist aber drop da findest
du die map nicht nicht so nice der 1008 schi übrigens danke leute für die ganzen subs
ich habe heute kaum was vorgelesen kaum was reingeguckt der hier hat gesagt max da hat
gesagt diese underscore hat gesagt infinity hat gesagt zli jumper krelax ist wieder am
start heißt johi ist wieder zuto punkt default netleader den hatten wir schon nice leute
danke für die subs auch falls ich übersehen habe so welche gpu hast du habe ich 1008
was meinst du was oben rechts die ganze zeit war das hatte ich doch oben an aber das ist
halt nicht sonderlich aussagekräftig finde ich das in dem auto das ist anti air so eine
anti air gettlingern das glaube ich das glaube ich nicht ich glaube der hauptmodus von bad
field 2042 wird schon bad field 2042 sein weil man muss halt auch sagen dass ich dann
auch wenn du grand pasar spielt grand pasar sich nicht wie in bad field 3 neu spielt
sondern halt wie bad field 2042 auf grand pasar wobei halt die map immer noch besser
ist als das ding da was man da jetzt hat ja das ist kacke das stimmt freund feinderkennung
ist nicht vorhanden wenn ich gerade zufällig der rot der der marker über den richtig ist
der teilweise mit verzögern kommt es ist vorbei es gibt blaufilter wenn du zu nah an die tanks
gehst die gefroren sind dann wird der bildschirm manchmal blau was kann werbstät näher den
grappling hook was mit abstand des ops dem ganzen spiel ist
das dachte ich mir auch schon kann wahrscheinlich oder steam ist doch da glaube steam ist doch
meistens recht ist doch recht recht gut sachen zurückzugeben kommt das game an bf3 release
dran bf3 release na gut bf3 release können wir schlecht vergleichen mit dem oder meinst
du vom feeling her jetzt schon nein weder maps noch noch der fluss noch noch alles nein
nein nein auf keinen fall bis jetzt
das game ist noch schneller als bf3 es muss aber auch schneller sein weil die maps groß
sind und es trotzdem schon clusterfuck oder langeweile
ok leute ich gehe jetzt ins bett ihr wisst 37 jähriger boomer ist früh müde und ich
muss morgen arbeiten gehen haust
ich gucke gerade mal jemand am start ist von denen den ich folge den cyrus haben wir letztens
erst gehostet wirst du jetzt keinen den ich hosten kann
solution ist am start vielfahrt 22 aber ich will euch jetzt kein vielfahrt zumuten und
ich würde lieber jemand kleineres hausen auch wenn er mich letztens gehostet hat aber der
braucht das reverse hausen glaube ich eher nicht hc bounty ach spielt der battlefield
gerade das ist ja ne oder spielt der battlefield 3 das spielt bestimmt battlefield 3 ne der
spielt battlefield 22 den können wir hausten ah werbung alter geh fort come on
ich gebe den rate schon mal ein ihr könnt ja ein bisschen oder irgendwas kann die werbung
mal please vorbeigehen ich will einfach sehen was er gerade so treibt nicht dass er gleich
aufgeht dass man schon drei stunden an aber er hat auf jeden also ich gucke von dem ultra
gerne die battlefield top top clips wenn er dabei ist da wird er sich freuen wenn er
be right back ist und 200 zuschauer art also leute wir sehen uns machts gut bis morgen
wahrscheinlich ich bin mir nicht sicher ob battlefield oder flaschen mal gucken wahrscheinlich
battlefield so lange es noch läuft morgen sind auch die ganzen open beta news am start
bis dahin machts gut co